morning everybody um we have a quite a
full schedule for the day so um we can
get started um with our first bill and
uh chairman lad is at a special chairs
meeting mandatory chairs meeting with
the speaker uh right now
so um representative Pell will chair
this hearing so I'll turn the mic and
peternell good morning morning um this
mine welcome to the house education
committee um the first hearing of the
day is House Bill
1176 establishing a commission to study
current funding for special education
and potential other funding sources and
with that we call on representative
Heath the prime sponsor of this Bill
thank you do I need to do a card yes
please okay I will do one um thank you
um it's nice to kind of be here I don't
do this very often um my name is Mary
Heath and I represent um the city of
Manchester and specifically WS 2 4 5 and
7 um I have been a longtime educator
actually I was an educator for over 42
years and once upon a time a long long
time ago I was the first special ed
teacher at Memorial High School after
94142 was passed so my history with
special ed goes back a long long way and
I've served in a number of different
capacities at the local level at the
state level at the department of Ed and
when I worked at Southern New Hampshire
University as um in the capacity of of a
teacher Ed program so um House Bill 1176
is designed to look at a few things but
most specifically the funding and and
I'm not going to take up the time
because I know you have a big agenda
today and I have U that there are people
here that will speak to the report that
I just handed out um and also the need
for us to look at special education but
more specifically the whole funding
issue and in the report you'll have
you'll see those issues and the urgency
that we really need to start thinking
and talking
about what can we do in the near future
to really compensate school districts
for the extraordinary cost that they've
had and we certainly know that uh the
old catastrophic Aid is quite a hurdle
for school districts to get even get
through that program you don't get the
money till the next year um and if you
have a student come in with huge costs
if you're a rural School District it's a
nightmare and the other all our kids
deserve the best possible education that
they can get and for families in our
state in a small rural School District
to be ostracized and intimidated because
they have a child with a severe
disability because of the cost is unfair
and not right and we need to come up
with some way to keep that from
happening um I I never even realized
something something like that could
happen because I had worked in
Manchester but when I went to work in a
small rural school district and we were
at a town meeting and I heard complaints
about a particular family and the cost
for a student their their child there's
no parent us to have a severely disabled
child and but they still we still need
to adhere to the law and we still need
to do the best for those children that
we can do so I'm going to end there
because I can go on for hours because
this subject has been eny of my heart
for a long long time um because all kids
and you know I loved what Dean said
yesterday when he a capital l capital a
capital l l um because really all kids
deserve an education and all kids can
learn to some extent so you know we are
really invested in our kids in New
Hampshire and we need to do a better job
so I am going to stop if unless you want
me to answer any questions but the
experts are behind me thank you very
much are there any questions for
representative Heath yes representative
Miler uh thank you madam chair and thank
you for being here uh you cited the
federal law
94142 would you please review that
because there are members of this
committee who are not I'm ass sure sure
are not familiar with the impact of that
and what it meant uh for special ed
students um and I'm sure Jen can do a
better job than I will do but um in in
um
1975 um the
um US Congress and Senate uh passed idea
which uh the individuals with disability
Education Act and when that happened it
required each School District to look
independently at each child that was
referred for special education and then
to come up with a an individual
education plan and then to provide the
necessary education and supports for
that child um when I first began um my
program at Memorial High School really
nobody really knew what special ed was
and I remember the principal way back
long ago um I had a student in a
wheelchair and she needed to take typing
and
typing before we had computers so I'm
really dating myself but the principal
would not move the class upstairs for
her so her mom and I unfort Al had to go
to the superintendent and explain Mr so
and so you know we need to do this well
anyway Memorial High School got an
elevator so it worked out well but there
are things that that there was a lot of
reticence um I remember the principal
said well I'm not going to turn my
school upside down for one student but
the thing is every child needs to have
that opportunity and
94142 made that possible um it's it's
been it's come a long long way um those
folks that are full-time people now know
uh the complexities that go along with
um special education uh at the
department of Ed we don't have as many
people as we used to have I don't know
why there used to be a lot of um a lot
more uh uh specialed uh Consultants that
would work with school districts but I
guess it's been hard to find people to
do that job because the cost is so great
but at any rate so that's that's what
idea is um 94142 and kind of made a big
difference and made us look differently
at our school system but most
importantly everybody gets to go to
school and a long time ago a lot of kids
didn't get to go to school the
difference is wonderful and you know
just being a teacher and watching um a
child um with Down Syndrome walk across
the stage when they graduate a child
that appear I had a student at Memorial
High School whose mother never thought
that he would live very long but he
lived long enough to get married and
have children and have a business of his
own and she to drive a car she was so
excited the day that he got his license
so the these are things that for so many
students we never thought that they
could do these things and they can
absolutely we we can never put box
around a student and say they can't
because you know what we all can come
out and do what we what what we can get
to different places so is that enough
follow follow up please yeah and and
with the federal enactment of
94142 what was the Federal obligation to
fund that's a long story
um that was going to be the the federal
government was going to pay 50% and I
think I'm not sure what it is now what
5% right around 5% and it really it has
had a huge impact on school districts
and I'm if any of you go to town
meetings you probably hear the
conversations that go on the
conversation should be about what can we
do for our kids not how much it's going
to cost all the time and I know we have
to be leery about cost but still the
child should be the the focus point of
our conversation and how we can help
them to become what we never thought
that they could become and and to do the
and they'll become citizens and our and
be a taxpayer so you know it's just they
need those and the state pays a certain
percentages and Zach's going to talk a
lot about that this morning so I'm going
to I'm going to stop talking because I
will talk too much and um he they will
take over and um give you the the most
updated information okay thank you any
other questions for representative Heath
yes representative cordelli uh thank you
madam
chair
um you mentioned uh the focus
specifically of this commission is on
funding not completely okay I maybe I
misunderstood what um if you read
through the the the whole thing it's
going to be looking at right I I I saw
the um the commission shells right
because so many of our
students right could I maybe I can ask
my question first okay go ahead thank
you
um on lines um five and six you talk
about um study specific Revenue sources
um on page two Roman five you talked
about current funding
sources and you even talk about on um
the uh last page um this commission to
come up with a draft proposal for future
funding legislation yes um I'm concerned
um about this commission and especially
looking at the makeup of this commission
I'm concerned about um
these people coming up with legislation
for funding special ed um could you
explain um why you think that that has
to be the focus of it and we already I I
see you handed out a um a report from
one
organization um that's also involved in
this uh commission so I'm not sure I'm
concerned about one um coming up with
legislation for funding and two the
makeup of the commission um seems um uh
slanted if I could say um given uh who's
on the commission uh could you speak to
to those concerns well when we put the
uh membership together um I worked with
the um uh across the street and we
talked about who might be on it um we we
also talked about the fact that when the
education committee took the bill um
that you may have some other ideas of
folks you might want to have on the
committee um but the fact is we we you
see that we do have a number of
representatives and Senators so I think
it's important some of the people are
that are listed one special educator
appointed by the different um
organizations um so I think this is a
commission that's going to take some
time but if you have other people that
you feel or um people that that
shouldn't be on there um it's your
purview to um make some amendments but
um what I'd like to ask is that that you
listen to the folks here uh behind me um
and and hear what they have to
say thank you any other
berson
good morning my name is Jane berson
bullu and I'm the executive director for
the New Hampshire Association of special
education administrators and I'm here
representing over 270 leaders in the
field of special education from both our
Public School settings as well as our
approved private special education
schools many of which have uh
Residential Treatment Centers and we're
here um to testify in support of the
bill and I'll keep my uh comments um
short you'll see in my testimony uh Mary
had done a nice job of kind of setting
the stage about the requirements that
all of our educational communities are
held to when it comes to uh provision of
special education services for students
with IEPs um the other thing that I
would add to um
representative um Mary Heath uh comments
is that um our educational communities
are responsible for children ages 3 to
22 um so it it's bigger than your
traditional uh Public School setting
when it comes to
responsibilities um as I have mentioned
in in previous uh testimony the costs uh
for special education services continue
to rise the number of students
identified um as students with IEPs
continues to grow and um the complexity
of our students continues to grow which
really drives up the costs the costs are
typically based on um specialized
instruction specialized in equipment
Staffing
transportation we provide services to
students with IEPs and Charter Schools
we cover the cost for students who are
placed out of district and out of state
and for those students with IEPs who are
engaged in the juvenile justice
system we our association really feels
that this bill would have the
opportunity to dig deeper and looking at
the costs associated with special
education the funding sources coming in
and would be an opportunity to hopefully
come up with um some suggestions for
consideration in addressing uh the
challenges when it comes to funding for
special education and some of the
inequities that we see uh within our Ed
educational communities across the state
um so thank you very much for the
opportunity to testify um and thank you
very much for the service that you
provide uh to our state thank you very
much are there any
questions representative
D thank you madam chairman thank you for
uh taking question um can you I know
that the catastrophic Aid which were
what it was formerly called covers the
the largest
uh amounts that have to be there can you
explain to me a little bit about is
there any percentage or is it is it
covered completely how are those kind of
costs covered and I don't have the exact
number but once um a students uh the
cost for a students reach um a certain
cap the department of Ed takes over the
costs um we've seen that the the
catastrophic Aid going to school
districts um over the years has gone
down um because uh um of changes in
paperwork or uh procedures not being uh
followed correctly so if the paperwork
isn't done correctly from my
understanding is that that districts
don't uh get their the monies
that that there should be allotted so
there's been some challenges and those
numbers have gone down and I don't have
the figures right with me does that
help thanks representative
Damon
thank you chair and thank you for taking
my question and being here could you
just summarize for those of us with not
complete background in special
ed the additional preparation that a
special educator special ed educator
would have and perhaps address why that
commission those who are seeking special
education teacher degrees um you know
their their programming is really
focused on the unique Learners um and
their varying types of disabilities
typically um those who are entering the
field of special education get an
endorsement called General special
education um and pretty typically
through their career um add on to that
and get additional endorsements that
specialize in specific disabilities so
you could have um an endorsement in
learning disabilities emotional and
behavioral
disturbances uh intellectual
disabilities um most of our special
Educators tend to specialize once they
follow do we have an excuse me do we
have enough people in New Hampshire with
that credentialing and training and if
not perhaps you could comment on your
perspective on why
not uh CR in New Hamshire special
education teachers is a critical
shortage area which means we um are
desperately um lacking staff um just
about every school district um and I I
don't have the numbers off of my top of
my head but we have many many vacancies
um when it comes to special education
teachers
um even more vacancies when it comes to
speech language Pathologists School
psychologists OTS
pts um paraprofessionals is even more
significant um we we don't have the
amount of par support that we need in
our school districts um reasons why um I
when we talk to the field I think it
it's very it's an extremely difficult
job the kids are are um very complex so
not only are you responsible for the
instruction and the specially designed
um instruction and related Services
you're also responsibility you're
responsible for all of the paperwork
that goes along with that and and the
timelines which are all important and
need to be there um but it's it's above
and beyond a typical teachers job in
addition um as I mentioned the kids are
getting much more complex and difficult
and we're seeing a lot of kids with um
mental health challenges um we're really
focusing on violent and aggressive kids
um our association is really working
with leaders to begin to address that
looking at the legal aspect looking at
the programming aspect and looking at
the the training aspect in addition for
these kids that um are very very
complex all of the placements are full
there we're lacking placements for
students to go um when we can't provide
programming within our own districts um
so it's there's many layers to the
challenge and we're also finding that
because of all these complexities in in
special education the pipeline going
into the field in our colleges and
universities for special
EDS is dropping
significantly um you know in talk with
Keen State College they were one of our
leaders in terms of special education
teachers and and years ago it would be
typical for you know to have 125 150 um
I think last year they had
15 um so it's it's a it's a a field
that's
difficulties th thank you representative
corello and then representative Hall
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question you referred to um
the number of IEP students continuing to
grow just now you're talking about
increased complexity of the problems to
what do you attribute these increases
you know I think there's several factors
um you know one is covid we were seeing
a a big influx of very young children
with complex needs who um lost a a huge
amount of uh socialization and
programming um at very young ages um
and so I we feel as though that's one
area the mental health challenges and
the numbers of kids being
identified um as having emotional um and
behavioral disorders um has risen
significantly um the number of kids with
autism um is continuing to grow
um and so those are the areas that we're
seeing um some pretty significant growth
and for those young kids a lot of it is
around the social emotional piece and
piece yes follow follow so in answer to
you talked about more increases um the
one thing I'm getting is is you
mentioned covid any any other reasons
just to go a little
deeper well I think we're seeing more
and more kids with mental health issues
who are being identified as needing IEPs
and specially designed instruction and
behavioral support so um the reason for
um more the increase in mental health
challenges I think that's
Nationwide um we're seeing um in New
Hampshire we have a huge opioid
challenge um we have you know lots of
complex family
situations um you know the reasons for
mental health can be wide and
deep thank you very much um we have
three more speakers lined up so after
representative Hall if you have a
question that could wait until for a
private conversation in the hallway or
if it's a really pressing issue
specifically related to this bill then
we will entertain it so representative
Hall thank you madam chair and thank you
m b for being here and to answer the
question um so recently the commission U
recently a few minutes ago uh was
referenced character ized as being
slanted do you think the members on this
commission are slanted the you know I
felt the a a broad representation and
obviously the individuals that are
selected um that's all open for
conversation I think the stakeholder
groups that are represented probably
would have um great input into the
challenges that we face and would be
able to lead us to the research and
kinds of information that will need to
you
um representative leus and then
representative
cascaden me oh you okay no I said
representative leus and then
representative cascaden yeah
yeah
um thank you for taking my question I
want to follow up on the
paperwork issue and all the paperwork
that has to be done and I'm
wondering a is that federally mandated
or is there some way to reduce that and
B is that something we can have the
commission also look at it is federally
and state mandated
um certainly the commission can look at
it I mean it's one piece of
documentation in terms of the
expectations around special education um
it's just a part of the game you know
when you go into it and you become kind
of an expert in the law and timelines
and it just just becomes a part of what
you do each and every day I was just
trying to eliminate a yes thank you I
was just trying to eliminate a barrier
to people going into that that's I don't
think there's any way around it okay
that's what I wanted to know thank Youk
you representative cascaden thank you
madam chair um and thank you Jane for
taking my question uh when I started as
a principal a disruptive student that
was uh identifying special ed was a
generally a student that was born uh
with fetal alcohol syndrome and it kind
of exploded the building because it was
such a different unique behavior that we
had not seen in a typical learning
disabled child but today um is there any
data on the number of special ed
students who have been born drug
addicted and is there a number or data
that um um can be identifiable with
adverse childhood um experiences because
those have both exploded in the field as
well as you know but I'm wondering if
there's data on
that I'm not aware of it but we can
certainly you know look at that I'm not
quite sure how in-depth we get with IEP
teams on medical um kind of challenges
yeah um but that's an interesting
question and we can do some research on
that for you
thank you thank you representative
cordelli thank you madam chair um thank
you uh for testifying today um first um
three or four years ago uh we passed
legislation uh to create the opportunity
for high-risk pools if you will uh
Insurance pools for special education
costs um being funded uh from possibly
District uh special ed Reserve accounts
to make up um the basis for these
high-risk pools but to my knowledge no
school districts have attempted to uh uh
try this to see how it can impact and
save costs on the local level do you
have any feel for why that is the
case you know I don't and maybe if we
talk to our superintendence association
um that's not something that our
association has been engaged in follow
up thank you um welcome perhaps
something the something the commission
could look at but also in relate to the
commission function um do you think that
the uh commission as as a perspective
member um would be hearing from parents
um in relation to special education
services I I see that um you talk about
the bill talks about Services required
and and so forth but some of the most
memorable testimony that I've heard
sitting here as a legislator has been
from parents
crying crying because they cannot get
services for their children um and so
I'm just wondering how that balances
with the funding nature of this at the
same time there is a performance audit
going on by the Legislative budget
assistant on special education services
being provided by the district um and
they are not looking at local operations
so I'm I'm
just maybe you can help me I'm a little
bit confused between the uh LBA audit um
the role of this um commission and also
um uh providing um uh opport
opportunities for parents to give input
and talk about services that aren't
being performed because it talks about
services that are required but statute
but nothing that about services that are
not being performed for these children
could
you answer that long-winded question for
me I'll try um first I was say our
association values and recognizes the
essential um voice of parents I mean
they are so intrical they know their
child the best um and they have to be a
part of um every aspect of the special
ed process from start to finish and
measuring along the way um we truly
believe that and always want parents to
be a a voice at the table um in terms of
this study versus the legislative audit
that's going on um the Bureau of special
education has been kind of keeping us
briefed on um some of the activities but
to my knowledge um the first phase the
first phase of the report hasn't become
public um so it's hard for me to to
comment on that um I would
see and again it's hard for me to
comment if I don't really know the
activities of the legislative audit and
what some of the findings are um at this
point to me this commission would be
digging very deeply into uh funding
aspects I would hope that parent voice
would be a part of that and that the
commission would be getting um input
from parents on variety perspectives of
what they're looking at through their
data um but to compare the two studies
at this point I really can't comment on
that I'm sure both of them will provide
us with uh important information and
probably the legislative audit will have
um some recommendations and data that
will feed the commission and things that
they won't have to research which would
resource representative
Ford my question to thank you for taking
my question my question is sort of a
followup to what was just asked you and
it gets into the causality of the
process um I have a somewhat unique
perspective on this process as you know
and my observation of it was that a lot
of the contention and frustration is it
comes when an IEP is challenged for not
meeting the thing and this community is
represented by attorneys and therefore
the parents feel the need to be
represented because they don't contend
well with the attorneys and it becomes
then legally contentious and a lot of
the irritation anger frustration stems
out of that particular Nexus uh with the
parents trying to argue for their child
and desperate as you know I mean we've
all experienced some version of that and
and then being me met by attorneys then
having to lawyer up themselves so the
cost goes up and I think part of it is
in that contention process and the towns
of course feel the need to be
represented by
attorneys and it just keeps going up and
up and
up and so the question question is and
my question is should we be looking at
perhaps the IEP process and how we make
a contract to meet the needs of specific
children so that it doesn't become such
a contentious process I would imagine
that maybe some of the cost associated
with that would be part of the
commission's work I think that the
legislative audit is covering some of
that and might give us some additional
information and um but you know I would
agree with you that many of the
conflicts right now center around lack
of services that seems to be a trend in
in talking with our department of Ed
that um you know we're lacking staff and
so there are times when kids aren't
getting their services and districts
know that and parents know it and we're
all doing our best to Rally around and
make those Services up when we need to
um but it is it is a source of conflict
thank you you're welcome thank you any
more questions from Miss
Bon thank you very much thank you very
much I'd like to call on um
representative Port
portelli representative portelli is a
bill good morning everyone and thank you
for having me my name is for the record
my name is representative Susan pelli I
represent Rockingham District 19 Hampton
Falls and Kensington although I am not
an expert in education or special
education funding I am an expert on what
happens when we have Federal mandates
that are not funded and the impact on
our kids and property tax
owners and I am here today in support of
this bill so that I hope that we could
shed some light on what's happening with
a topic that affects every single one of
us and that is how to re look at special
education look at all the aspects of it
understand the cost drivers and provide
some relief for our property tax owners
this is critically important to uh make
sure part of the conversation is to
include the federal funding that we
desperately need for special education
services to help reduce our property
taxes for our new H struggling New
Hampshire residents and provide for the
increasing needs of students with
special disabilities and I'm sure you
all know this but for context in 1975
Congress passed a comprehensive law
protecting and improving the outcomes of
children and their families with
disabilities in 1990 the law was
reauthorized and changed to the
individuals with disabilities Education
Act or
idea the the Ida federal laws that we
are mandated to comply with include
services that must be provided to
children with disabilities in elementary
and secondary school and I'm sure you're
very familiar with all of the different
requirements such as IEPs Etc but it
does not cover all of the costs these
federally
mandated uh requirements are very
expensive to administrator and the ieda
ACT originally proposed only covered 40%
of the cost and that was back in
1990 however Congress has never
appropriated the uh required Monies to
come to our cities and towns and this
has resulted in an unfunded mandate and
it shifts the costs for educating
students with special needs to the
states and especially our school
districts and I think we're seeing that
impact now in the two small communities
that I represent there was currently a
revaluation of their property their
taxes have gone Sky High due to the
revaluation in addition to that um many
of the special Education costs are
increasing faster than our budget our
school budgets can
allow children and taxpayers need to
understand what these cost drivers
are and alarming 26 New Hampshire Public
School Districts spend over
25% of their total school budget on
special education costs I would like
this commission to do a deep dive and
understand what special education
instruction needs to include from a
federally mandated and state mandated
perspective how these Services can be
delivered in a more effective manner
what are the outcomes and how are we
measuring success I'd like to look at
the ad the exploding administrative
costs and see what we could do to make
sure we get that under control the legal
fees as you have mentioned the legal
fees are borne by the town and many of
these lawsuits uh turn into yearlong
processes at very expensive cost to the
town and of course Transportation which
is also an incredibly expensive Cost
needs to be um needs to be understood so
I come at this from a different
perspective I want to make sure that we
shed some light and put sunshine on what
happens with our special education needs
we have needs from our parents and our
students and we have mandates from our
federal government that were never
appropriated the funding appro
appropriated funding for it and now our
cities and towns are stuck in the middle
so I would respectfully ask that you
please consider this commission to look
at all aspects of special education and
especially the federally uh Fally
funding opportunities that we have that
our federal delegation needs to make
sure they are living up to their
expectations so thank you very much I'll
take any questions thank you very much
representative portelli do you have any
written testimony that you to submit to
the committee oh I I can after this
thank you any questions for the
representative representative
leus do you have any specific ideas for
um things that can be changed or
eliminated that are federally mandated
but not necessarily helpful well that's
certainly something I hope the U the
commission can look at so for example in
U New Hampshire and I'm sure you guys
know all these stats but I was just
amazed the total New Hampshire education
off operating expenses for 2122 was
about $3.5 billion total uh special ed
cost expenses were 800 million the
federal government and local um local
governments only only account for about
20% of the additional funding and we
have about uh 20% of our students or
300,000 students requiring Special
Education Service
and of course these costs as you know
shift dramatically from District to
District so the number of students
requiring these Services could go down
but the budgets can be doubled so it's
very important for this commission to
take a um objective
bipartisan comprehensive look at where
we're spending all the all of our
dollars making sure the services are
delivered appropriately but but then
some type of measurement to make sure
that these services are in fact
delivering what they promised thank you
thank you any other
questions representative dry thank you
madam chairman thank you for taking my
question uh in the request in the
resolution hcr1 to uh ask our delegation
to look into the funding the full
funding of federal mandates um if it
were fully funded how much of an impact
you think that would have on our state
right now uh it would obviously it would
have a significant impact the um the
budget for the US Department of
Education is over $80
billion so we really need to understand
where is that $80 billion going and this
is something that I hope the commission
plus the resolution will be able to
address to find out why is it taking
taking so long for the federal
government to live up to its promise to
fund appropriately an act they put into
law in 1990 it would have it would be a
game Cher for
us thank you further questions thank you
very much representative portal thank
you next we have Kristen
manani uh from the office of the special
education
advocate
welcome is this your first time
testifying before our
you good morning does that work better
thank you uh Kristen manman Office of
the special education Advocate which was
created
um probably more than a year ago but my
position was filled uh just a handful of
months ago so definitely very heavily
involved in work in this field and uh to
be
specific work on behalf of families who
are seeking special education services
that they don't feel like they're
getting for their students so we're
seeing kind of the the deep in the woods
um view of what's happening with special
education and I don't want to repeat a
lot of the testimony that you've already
heard um I just would like to put in um
two or three thoughts uh for the
committee if we are looking at this
financing piece one I would tell you
this is anecdotal at this point because
it's just going off of the cases that
have come into my office but 50% of the
disputes I would say about Services um
in special education are really related
to vacancies they're not related to
districts not wanting to provide the
services um so uh Miss beron spoke about
this I would hope that any look at
finances really looks at um getting
better data because it's something we
all in this community have to do in
terms of data on where all of the um
open positions and and it's special
Educators but it's also related services
and I think that's really important to
understand because if we dug down at my
guess is funding for the special
education teachers is you know only a
part of and I have no idea at this point
what percentage but you know probably
not more than half um and the related
service providers who are in speech
language pathology and occupational
therapy and mental health um Services
School psychologists working through
IEPs um is a huge portion of the rest of
it it is needed um having these
positions open means we're spending the
dollars later on because what I'm seeing
is the more we have students who don't
get the services they need younger even
if districts wanted to provide them they
don't have a speech language pathologist
or they don't have enough of them um
speech language Pathologists don't just
work on things like articulation they
work on communication skills for our
students who are diagnosed with autism
or mental health um they run social
groups they they really help those
students to integrate into the life of
the school so that at some point
potentially with young students the idea
is to bring some of them off of
individual education plans because their
needs have been met which would decrease
um the need for those Services through
age
22 uh so really looking funding wise at
getting data
on whether these positions are going to
be filled as Miss beron said I think
we're heading into more of a crisis
rather than less in that we don't have a
pipeline to fill some of the related
services that that are needed so
thinking about creative ways for how are
we going to over the next 10 and 20
years have those positions filled so
that Services can be delivered that
would cut down on a lot of the
disagreement pieces you it would cut
down on some of the the legal costs um
for these fights because from the
parents perspective they they have no
control over whether or not someone is
in the position they just know that
their child needs services that they're
not getting so they're going to enter
into that fight for which there may be
no solution until we figure out how to
get positions filled so um there is
there are probably Creative Financial
ways to to ensure that we have a
pipeline into those special Educators
par educators and related service
providers and I think that's something
that um data is is very important to
gather um
annually on open positions in that field
and on the the numbers of positions in
those fields across the state are they
are they increasing are they
needs that that's probably my most
important point in this is really
looking at um you know these are dollars
now for young children or dollars that
are ongoing later and so I think that we
want to make sure that we're really
looking at um the efficacy of the
dollars spent and and making sure that
that's built into any committee studying
finances I'm happy to take any questions
if you have them thank you very much
representative Miler thank you madam
chair and welcome for your first uh
hearing here I can recall um the piece
of legislation that basically created
that position and uh much needed
position uh since since is your first
opportunity to be before the committee
could you give us a bit of a background
of your uh special education history
that got you to this position right so
my history was less in special education
actually um I had both a legal
background and a background in education
not special education per se um I uh was
a
lawyer practiced for some years in
litigation um and then ran a school for
about 15 years where as an administrator
um in a private school we definitely
dealt with IEPs and um working with
public school districts on IEP Services
we had our own um related service
providers within the school so uh those
pieces all come into play I hope to help
um work with families to Advocate and in
in some instances you know a lot of it
has been solving very longstanding
disputes with their districts um over
services for their children we're
dealing with a lot of Crisis situations
where children are you know have been
out of school for months or more have
been in mental health facilities as a
long progression of potentially not
getting services that they needed that
landed them there and we're you know
having to walk that back because those
children do come back into the schools
and and there are a lot of costs
associated with that so um what I tried
to do is use both the educational
administrator lens and um background in
law not special education law per se um
to bring some balance to uh solving
situations for
families thank you any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much Mrs M Rani did I say your name
thank you um with that we call on um
Becky
name uh good morning members of the
House committee thank you for hearing my
testimony today uh for the record Becky
Wilson I am the director of governmental
relations for the New Hampshire school
boards Association uh for anyone who
hasn't worked with me previously prior
to taking this position several years
ago I served as a special education
director here in the state for about 20
years um nhba supports this bill we'd
like to thank the sponsors of this bill
for highlighting the need to look at
special ed funding and look at the
complexities of funding in this state
for special
education um our public Ed costs as
everyone on this committee knows are
largely paid by local community
taxpayers Through Your local property
taxes um and while certainly nhba would
acknowledge that some immediate relief
is needed for our local communities it's
also very important that uh this
commission is able to take into account
um the numerous aspects of special ed
funding that are not easy to determine
and not clear in a one-time one fits all
solution
um we have several long-standing
resolutions around speci special
education funding uh and as you've heard
I won't repeat the federal funding
obligation has never been met uh while
there is a bill currently uh before our
federal delegation called the idea full
funding act uh whether or not that will
pass I think is yet to be seen that
would only again um if it were to pass
by some small miracle um allow uh states
to to get up to 40% of the special
education costs that they incur uh so I
think it's quite
if history repeats itself I think the
likelihood of that bill going anywhere
is probably not that not that high but
we can always keep trying um and NH hsba
certainly supports any full funding from
the federal uh government that we can
get in terms of meeting their obligation
there are a myriad of costs associated
with meeting the provisions of idea at
the state and federal levels and I think
it's very key to remember that New
Hampshire has decided to exceed the
federal idea in several areas which also
changes cost at the state level um we
also fund all of the uh services for
students who are eligible for special
education at Charter Schools the
resident district is responsible for
those costs we to my knowledge New
Hampshire is the only state that funds
specialed at charter schools in that
manner um the timelines in New Hampshire
in several areas are shorter than what
the federal idea requires so that also
uh can have effects on costs in
districts if you are trying to meet
tighter timelines in order to determine
eligibility the ability to use staff um
becomes more difficult you need more
staff to meet shorter timelines uh we
have higher parental consent
requirements in some areas than the
federal idea also requires which uh
leads to more meetings that need to
happen in a short period of time which
requires Staffing and things like that
um it's also I think really important to
remember that New Hampshire has been at
the Forefront of the inclusion movement
for many many decades um and just
because uh inclusion is a more General
Ed least restrictive environment for
many children does not mean that it is
cheaper than providing services in
different ways um I ALS districts and
specialed admin are in a position to try
to forecast needs for their Community
sometimes a year to 18 months ahead of
time when they are budgeting the budget
process in New Hampshire um for school
districts most often starts almost a
year if not longer in some districts
ahead of time trying to predict out uh a
three-year-old to 22y Old system 18
months out I don't know if any of you
have your own children but I can't even
predict my own children's needs 18
months out a year out um those things
change over time and a lot of times
those costs um that are incurred by
local districts are being coming off of
decisions that are certainly in the best
interest of children and are meeting
their obligation for idea but we're not
budgeted for because there was no way to
consider those when the B budget was
built the year before um it's a complex
funding formula for special ed in the
state as many of you know you have your
base adequacy your differentiated Aid
there is special ed Aid or catastrophic
Aid you have Medicaid to schools you
have Federal Ida grants you have
preschool obligations you have tuition
agreements the number of moving Parts
Charter Schools all of those pieces fall
into the costs that uh local districts
are incurring for special education
provision
um lastly I would like to just remind
people that I think um there's a lot of
conversation in this committee about the
Fidelity of the special education
process and concerns about the fact that
uh costs may be somehow driven up by
funding people want more funding so
they're going to change the eligibility
process for example to try to gain more
funding at the local level uh I think
nhba would argue that districts are
trying to balance meeting their idea
obligations and following the processes
that are very prescriptive and spelled
out in the New Hampshire rules with
being fiscally responsible for lack of a
better term um it's very difficult uh to
look at all of those pieces and make a
decision as an IEP team about what the
students needs are without considering
the financial obligation that the
district is going to incur by making
that decision and that is what we ask
teams to do every day is to make
decisions that are for individual kids
without any concern or consideration of
what it's going to cost that is what we
are required to do um and the district
is then on the hook for making sure they
can figure out how to do that um many
times as you've heard me say before in
front of this committee that is at the
expense of the General Ed programming
because districts don't have an
obligation necessarily to provide all of
the things that are in the budget for
the General Ed programs but they are on
the hook for special ed Provisions um
and lastly I would just say uh the best
special ed is a very strong regular Ed
program I I've heard many people on this
committee ask why are the numbers going
up if you don't have a strong General Ed
program or you have teachers and this is
not as um meant negatively towards
teachers who are on alternative pathway
they've not gone through teacher prep
programs General Ed teachers have a high
obligation to meet certain aspects of
students IEPs if they are coming out of
programs where they haven't yet learned
those things uh if they are coming from
a place where they're on alternative
certification process and they have to
be overseen by people um Regular Ed
teachers sometimes may not realize what
might rise to the level of a referral or
what might kick something over into
special education so you're going to get
a lot more concerns brought forward
which some are very valid I'm not trying
to say that they're not um but if you
don't have a system that is able to
provide help to all students and the
only way for students to get help is to
become identified then certainly you're
going to see some changes in that um
it's going to drive up your number and I
think that um the reason this commission
is so needed is that there was many
moving Parts like that that I think if
there was some time given to look at the
whole system and look at the system as a
whole you might be able to answer some
of your own questions on this committee
that come up repeatedly about why
certain things are happening um and the
costs then would be much more reflective
of true special education need and not
necessarily systems issues that are
happening across certain districts in
the state um I'm happy to answer any
questions thank you
representative
luus thank you for taking my
question you mentioned that in some
areas were even more strict than the
Federal Regulations my question is are
there
areas that there are that the federal
government has um made mandates on us
which perhaps are not so useful or that
if question yeah I appreciate the
question
um without going back in and looking at
every individual piece of the federal
idea I would say that my experience with
most federal legislation is it's sort of
a barebone situation so I would imagine
that the majority of idea um
requirements are mandatory in order to
ensure that students are getting an
appropriate free education
um across the state thank you you're
welcome representative belter thank you
man Jer uh thank you for your testimony
I just wanted to clarify one point that
I that was brought up because you you
mentioned that the best I believe you
said defense against having to expand
special education programs is in fact a
strong regular education program I'm not
sure I fully understood that because my
understanding of special education is
it's for students with disabilities so
that I are you suggesting that education
itself can induce
disabilities thank you for the question
I'm not saying that
um we have 13 categories of disability
here in the state every single category
has very specific criteria that students
must or teams must consider when they're
trying to decide whether or not a child
is eligible for special
education there in any classroom there
are I'll say 20 students who have 20
different learning styles 20 different
ways of expressing what they know Etc um
for strong regular Ed programs that
offer for example differentiated
instruction lots of different ways to
show what you know um many students will
will be able to show what they know in a
very competent way if you only in one
room allow one way for students to show
what they know and you have a child who
that's not their way of showing what
they know um it's going to look like
maybe they don't know the content so
strong regular Ed in New Hampshire has
been built off of differentiated
instruction a lot of other programming
that allows for multiple ways for
students to show their competency for
example um it allows students who are
still struggling to sort of rise to a
level where there would be a concern
that is truly based on the students
needs versus a break in the system if
that makes
sense a lack of offerings what the child
would need in the first place
Excuse me yes follow I made just to
further clarify a little bit so let's
say you have a student who's not good at
taking tests and they that's their way
that's being tested in the classroom
it's a written test and they and they're
not performing well but there's not an
underlying disability there it's just
not a good test taker are you suggesting
that such a student could wind up being
placed in a special education program
even though there's no disability
present thank you for the question I'm
saying that I think in that situation if
you had um people with less experience
at as Educators for example that I'm
just using this as an example but a
teacher who is coming from
another profession who wants to be a
teacher and is on an alternative plan
and is supervised by someone else if
they don't understand necessarily or
haven't had
experience asking themselves that
question if it is the way in which the
student is being tested that is the
issue or if it is an issue in terms of
the students learning if they don't have
that background they may make a referral
to special ed it doesn't mean the
student would be necessarily identified
as needing special education because
there is a very long process that goes
through once that referral is made but
schools are not in a position to be able
to say we're not taking that referral
the Ida is very clear that when you get
a referral you need to dispose of it you
need to meet on it you need to meet with
a certain number of days there are
certain people that need to be at that
meeting that process is started you
can't say no thank you so I think you
would get to a point where with strong
evaluations which is what happens in the
special ed process you would determine
that it's really a mismatch of um
environment versus student actually
needing specially designed instruction
that is significantly different than
other
people thank you that was very useful
information you're welcome thank you any
other
questions thank you Miss Wilson thank
you and our final speaker is Zach Shen
correctly thank you thank you members of
committee um for the record Zach shien
I'm the executive director of the New
Hampshire school funding fairness
project as often happens I have in
testimony prepared but I after
everything everyone's saying I I'm going
to bounce around because I don't want to
repeat a lot I know people have gone
through a lot and folks who have much
more detailed expertise in special
education
specifically um what I do want to hit on
though is kind of the funding um piece
that the commission would be looking at
um so just a tiny bit of
background uh here in New Hampshire we
rely primarily on local property taxes
to pay for public education total public
education about 70% of all um
expenditures for public education in the
state are covered by local property
taxes that's about 60% local property
tax 10% swept which as you know swept is
a local property tax because it's raised
retained and kept
locally um to put some numbers around
special education funding specifically
um the 21 2022 school year there are
about 30,000 students receive special
education services um the total costs
which have been referenced before for
special education services um are around
$840 million uh for that same
year um and then we've uh kind of
mentioned a number of times the lack of
funding from the federal government and
where that plays into this I think it is
an important conversation I think that
hcr1 that was mentioned earlier is an
appropriate um Step that the legislature
can take to demand action of the federal
government um but as was pointed out in
testimony I think repeatedly last week
uh waiting for that when it has not come
through in decades I think is not um
taking a logical approach to solving
school funding um for now so I think the
HCR is a really helpful approach to
asking how that's going to be solved but
hoping it comes through when it hasn't
in the past I think um and contining to
Kick the Can down the road currently is
is not a helpful approach for our
students uh right now um just to give a
little um background on some of the kind
of impacts on specific school districts
it was just mentioned earlier about 20
26 uh school districts um it's year 2021
2022 had over 25% of their budget was
special education cost and this can vary
greatly especially for a lot of our
smaller rural districts um if a student
moves in has significant needs that can
really change a budget and how why you
know why we have a system right now
where a family needs to fear tension at
the grocery store because the community
knows that their child is receiving
additional services and those are being
born primarily by local property taxes
like that is a broken system in which
families or students are you know
feeling penalized as representative
Heath mentioned for receiving the
services that they are entitled to and
that their students need um their
children need to
succeed relative to um HB 1176
specifically uh we think this is an
important um Bill an important step um
towards looking at solving what is you
as you heard a very very complex problem
I would like to point out specifically
the elements that I think um have not
been touched on uh previously which is
the funding element so how are we paying
for public education at large what are
the revenue sources used for that and
then specifically with this bill the
revenue sources for covering the roughly
million that we are currently raising
with local property taxes to cover
special education services right so $
680 million is the amount that is
currently being raised and spent for
special education services coming
directly out of our local property taxes
and the way we look at this is this bill
provides a few elements I think they
were referenced earlier that look at
what are potential fund what are current
funding sources and what are other
potential funding sources for both
special ation but at large public
education um and I would just encourage
you know as a project we would encourage
that the commission be explicit in
looking at Revenue sources all of them
as many as possible not just property
taxes other states we might find that
they have different um Revenue sources
different specific ways of delivering
those revenues to special education
funding I would really encourage that to
make this a useful and helpful
commission to help provide ideally
future budget writers in the in the
legislature the the resources and tools
to try to address this would be what are
the other Revenue sources that are used
and really looking at an expansive
approach talking about taxes here in New
Hampshire is often uh not done frankly
and um I think that this provides an
opportunity to look at what taxes are
used in other states why are they used
who pays them what's the impact and how
does that help as we've heard relieve
the burden on on local property
taxpayers in the state many in rural
communities that are really bearing the
system lastly um relative to timing I
would just um suggest that the timing of
this commission reflect the next
legislative budget process because I
think that is when there is a really
significant opportunity to enact some of
these changes so we would suggest that
that be bumped up a little bit I think
the first report is currently as written
due end of January 2025 that's a little
late for the budget process um I would
just suggest that it be you know due the
end of the calendar year 2024 so that um
the governor's office um can be
incorporating some of those potential
changes into their own budgeting process
and the house waves means and finance
well um lastly I just wanted to me
answer two last questions and I'm happy
to answer any remaining questions um I
did see that the report that we prepared
um was passed out by representative
Heath this is something we prepared last
October I don't know if this was what
was mentioned earlier um relative to the
report and folks serving on the
commission but I just want to clarify
that we as an organization are not named
as a participating member in the
commission just so that that's clear um
I didn't I didn't know which report was
being held up in reference to that
question
earlier um and then also
uh relative to just a number of the
questions that have been asked recently
around what are the services students
are getting and how how do we make sure
they're getting the services they need
and I would just encourage this
commission to not focus entirely on what
things can we cut or what things can we
reduce or where can we limit pieces in
order to try to help a little bit that
might be helpful in some areas it's
definitely good to look at where there
are inefficiencies but we're talking
about was $700
million that is currently being raised
by local property taxes at wildly
different rates to pay for special
education services and so making sure
that this commission as currently
written looks at what are other Revenue
sources that could come into the system
to help relieve that burden and shift
who is paying so that who is paying is
not Charles stown at a rate of four or
five times higher than some of their
neighboring communities we're looking at
how this impacts different communities
specifically and understanding that
relying on local property taxes as much
as we do is at the at the core one of
the major um challenges we're all facing
so with that I'm happy to answer uh any
questions any
questions representative Dr thank you
madam chairman thank you for taking a
question so the first thing that comes
into my mind with uh alternate revenue
streams is something like bringing the
lottery system in to pay for education
and something like that but are you
thinking more like what different taxes
can we do for
Revenue so just to be clear right now
the lottery all of the lottery does go
into education um all of the you know
money left over from after they give out
the winnings and pay for the staff and
the structure so that's a current
existing Revenue Source yes the bill
outlines looking at what other states do
for Revenue how how they they pay for
public education as a data collection
what do they do does it work does it not
work is it helpful is it Equitable or
not um so yes looking at other Revenue
sources and how they could either be if
there's new Revenue sources what that
impact would be so for example talking
about sales and income taxes in New
Hampshire is generally seen as you don't
go there right but a commission that
could say okay other states they have
income taxes they have sales taxes they
have different business taxes those are
just facts what would that look like in
New Hampshire cuz then you all have that
information then you all have that data
would that help relieve local property
taxes if it were directed towards
special education funding specifically
so that Winchester doesn't have to spend
you know rely so much on their local
property taxes in these dramatic
variations so as we I read the bill
that's the intent of the bill and I just
wanted to highlight the importance of
examining what other Revenue sources are
but also what the impact on New
Hampshire is so that as we're having
policy debates about what Revenue
sources are best to use we have property
tax right now we can compare that to
other other ways so that you have the
information there to say this would be
helpful for these communities this would
be helpful for these communities and
make informed decisions is that helpful
it is thank you okay thank you for the
question okay thank you very much no
further questions we will close the
hearing on House Bill
yes
yes cards next one have any cards for
next
first we're going to begin the hearing
on House Bill 1639 relative to children
with disabilities placed at State
facilities for adjudicated youth I call
on representative cascaden the prime
sponsor of this Bill thank you uh Madam
chair for the record Karine cascaden
representing uh Coos District 5 the city
of Berlin I'm here to present this bill
on behalf of the Department of Ed it has
to do with changing the terminology of
students students who are adjudicated
and placed in facilities so if you look
at the Bell the same terminology is
corrected throughout instead of using
the Youth Services Center um the
recommendation is to put is to call it
State facilities for adjudicated Youth
and County correctional facilities
um and it is throughout um I am familiar
this is pretty much out of District to
give you my background I grew up
bilingual and went to college and
majored in foreign languages because it
was easier um but then went into
teaching and started in secondary Ed at
the time there was lots of federal money
for bilingual education and they um
provided me with tuition to be certified
as an elementary school classroom and
taught bilingual Ed in Middle School
um from there went into administration
of elementary schools and was a very
active part of the special ed process
from the referral to the disposition to
the um
evaluations um to the
placements uh outer District placements
were rare but sometimes necessary I made
multiple trips visiting students at
Prospect Academy at Spalding at Easter
seals at ELC at Pine Haven um because
they were our
students so I have significantly
participated in the special ed
process um so I have um the department
of Ed E pet is here and attorney Fenton
to answer any specific questions um on
the change in terminology for this bill
so it's that's pretty much it it doesn't
really change thank you very much
representative cascaden are there any
questions for representa
cascaden yes represent Damon thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question so I just want to clarify it
seems to me that this is simply changing
the language because we don't have a
Youth Services Center as such
anymore or is it um suggesting other
kinds of placements that are already
happening under different
terminology no it's based primarily I
suspect and you can get more accurate
information from um Becky is that the
Youth Services Center is not an existent
facility and as you know the state is
talking about what kind of facility to
have but at least this terminology would
cover anything for an adjudicated youth
whether in a state facility thank you
any further questions not see any thank
you very much you're welcome I'd like to
invite Rebecca fet Rebecca's here from
the Department today she is not taking a
position she is here to provide support
to
us thank you representative lad um I am
rebecc Fett I'm the state director of
special education at the Department of
Education um we did ask for this bill
because if you look through the language
just on this page there are some
inconsistencies between the Youth
Services Center um the youth the Youth
Development Center um and then with the
possibility of the sonunu Youth Services
Center changing we wanted to make the
language more generic so that we
wouldn't have to keep coming back to you
to change the name um that was purely
the reason that we did this and tried to
make it so that it would cover anything
um that might come up that would need to
be used this language I did just speak
with some of my colleagues at DHHS there
may be one piece that may have a
conflict in it um on line 26 for
students awaiting disposition so I might
be going back to representative cascaden
to just make an adjustment but that is
why we put this forth was just to make
the language more generic and not have
to keep coming back to change what
facility this might be and I'll take any
questions if you have them thank thank
department yes represent Bon uh thank
you chairman lad and thank you for
taking my question I'm just curious why
it has a financial note we were asked
for a financial note um but it doesn't I
don't have it with
me thank you it shouldn't have any
but further further
questions thank
you are there any other pink cards for
yeah no because she just said she had
never mind never mind uh Direct for that
can can you get together and try to get
some uh of that modifying amending
language together with representative
cascaden right off here so possibly this
today so we don't start the next hearing
10:45 so we have a
I want to uh announce one thing for all
committee
members as been has just recently been
put out by
leadership the speaker all blurbs all
committee reports will be handed in to
the chair the day of the exec
session part of this as result of um we
initially had set aside Thursday
this week for and there was no no
committee reports being filed even
though bills had been
EXA and so the delay is is an issue so
be prepared to write your blurs your
committee reports and have them handed
in before you leave the given dat that
the Bill's been EXA so that's going to
take a lot of work and a lot of planning
and you're not going to note that next
we I have scheduled all kinds of bills
um if you have any involvement with any
of the bills you might get together
either with represent Miler or or myself
and um discuss it but we will try to
represent mil and I will try to look at
this list and see which ones we are
going to be taking up but it's not going
to stop us from taking anything that's
on the agenda we need to make sure we
have
the yeah yeah we that now we'll have
extra hard copies for the reporting form
available here or it can be done by way
of the
technology um so that
well we're that's going to create a
burden on many here but it's going to
expedite we have 107 bills which we got
to exact so we're going to have to get
those reports in a timely manner
especially these early bills which are
coming up and do out of this committee
by the 15th of the next of February so
that's that so we will get copies of the
form and make it available we'll keep
them on the table back there um and put
them for committee members only those
would be the committee reports everybody
up in the meeting I was is just calling
them blurbs because that's the
historical way of calling these things
so if you hear me talk blur I'm talking
committee
reports thank you and the the minority
will continue to hand in their committee
reports when they're done to represent
Myer he feeds some to me and then for
the majority members there for the
Republicans they will hand them directly
to me before before they
break um I'll have to be leaving after
the morning on
good
was and for the committee members
there's there I have one other represent
leus yes I I have one other comment for
you to know that we are going to have a
situation sometimes where the the prime
sponsor or any sponsor is not here to
present the bill we often times identify
somebody on the committee to go ahead
and present that bill if this person
just presents that bill without getting
into a discussion about the bill just
presents the bill they may come back to
their chair and they may ask
questions uh but if you get that person
for example it's going to happen this
afternoon the prime sponsor of the bill
for the uh military connected students
uh 1382 is not here I've been asked to
present it seeing I'm also military but
I'm not going to get any discussion on
the bill and so if there's nobody else
here to discuss it then we would just
have an executive session later on on
the bill and if you have questions about
it you talk to the prime sponsor who
wasn't there but the bill was introduced
so that's the way we're going to work
you
okay we're ready to go ahead with the
next bill uh which is HB 1480 relative
to Alternative dispute resolution within
individualized education programs and
like to welcome representa cascaden
thank you Mr chair for the record Karine
cascaden representing Coos District 5
city of Berlin I'm here to present
another bill on behalf of the Department
of Ed that has to do with uh alternative
dispute resolution um within the IEP
process I already um already want to add
an amendment to line six um part six
line six instead of the verbiage of the
department shall adopt rules it's a
state board of education so the
department will do it on behalf of the
State Board of
Education um it is to put back in law
the IEP facilitation process which is um
a process that can be um used prior to
going to fullo process or more extensive
um
resolutions the IEP facilitation process
has has been in place and it has been in
practice and in 2002 um that's when it
first started and that's an independent
person that the school and the parent
agrees to have at a ni meeting they're
not there to make decisions they're
there to add guidance or uh and
facilitate the meeting so that there's
Mutual um decision making in
2015 Senate Bell 166 was put on the
table to repeal the IEP facilitation
process and so the department would like
to put that back into statute um and the
reason is that in a recent audit um
their practice of doing I IEP
facilitation is is on their website it
describes what you need to do how you
need to do it the application or the
paperwork is there but in the audit it
was described that you couldn't exhibit
you could not have this practice without
legislation to support it so this this
bill 1480 supports the IEP facilitation
process that has been in place it's just
connecting the
two thank you very much are there any
questions for representative
cascaden yes represent Miler uh yes
thank you uh could you repeat what you
wanted to change in that particular line
please yes it is on um part six line
six it says the original bill says the
department shall adopt rules and it
should have been the State Board of
rules any further questions represent
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my
question did I understand you to say
that this is putting IEP facilitation
back into
statute yes so it was previously in
statute and removed
it was revoked uh with Senate Bill 166
in
um the bill was only to repeal
facilitated individualized education
program
meetings I don't have the history on it
so okay um I don't know are there
further
questions thank thank you very much
yep uh excuse me Mr chair questions so I
need to amend it as uh with the
language like we just the other what we
just talked about yes y okay thank
you Rebecca do you have anything to add
one Rebecca fet from the Department of
Education special education good morning
um we asked for this um to be added back
in as um representative cascaden said we
have been in an audit with the
Legislative Office Building um and one
of the things that came up was that this
was not in legislation in 2015 it was
repealed and it was thought that at the
time that we could continue to do IEP
facilitation without it being in
legislation however um through the audit
process we were told that we cannot so
we've always had the process the process
has never stopped it's been going since
2002 um and we want to continue the
process so we're asking to have it put
back into
legislation
so do you agree with the wording change
yes I
do representative McDonald thank you Mr
chair and thank you for your expertise
in this area um my question is why was
it repealed from law so from what I read
in the um documents from the statement
the Senate bill it stated that um the
person who presented that it should be
removed said that it could be done
without um being in legislation and that
it would make it a less adversarial
process I believe was some of the
wording that was used okay thank you I
wasn't there represent cordelli uh thank
you uh thank you for um being here um
are there any differences in the people
who can attend a facilitated
IEP uh that are different than
Ida um outline of who are participants
in an IEP I I talked to someone um who
participated in in one not long ago and
he said there was 14
people
um uh there from the uh Administration
if you will versus uh him and the um
parent that he was with could you speak
to the participants in a facilitated IEP
sure is so this should still be the same
participants that are required by Ida it
shouldn't have any additional people
beyond the IEP facilitator um this is
typically used when the district and the
parents are can't come to an agreement
on something or they're having
difficulty getting through the meeting
and getting their their work
accomplished so they ask for us to send
this neutral party to come to the
meeting to just literally run the
meeting and make sure that we're they're
Crossing all their eyes dotting all
their tees doing what they're supposed
to and um help them to come to
resolution between the two of them they
there shouldn't be any extra or
additional people that are needed at the
meeting um they are becoming adversarial
because this is kind of the beginning of
the dispute resolution process so there
may be a few additional people because
it is becoming adversarial but there's
no requirement for that there's no um
nothing that says that that should be
happening follow up um thank you
um since um the audit um indicated that
this should be in legislation be it's in
practice and it should therefore be in
legislation um it seems to me that there
are great number of things that we have
in practice that are not in um Federal
Ida law or state law uh should not those
legislation yes I mean anything that is
in practice but not in legislation
yes further questions represent Miley
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
being here I've got three questions
sure since we're going to put this back
in into
law can you outline for us please I'm
sure you thought about this what would
be the
rule what kinds of rules would the State
Board be adopting as far as what the
language be and what the uh the the
volume and area that this would cover
sure so um as we've discussed with the
Auditors through this dispute resolution
audit um we would go into rule to
explain how the process should look when
it is we really already have procedures
in place place but they have asked us to
look at rules to um set parameters on
how this should run how many people
discussing I'm sorry there's a lot of
things they've told me so it's all
running through my brain right now um
making sure that if there's a conflict
of interest we have um information
regarding how to notify a of a conflict
of interest how the process runs um who
how many people how many um cases can be
heard by an IP facilitator in a year all
of those parameters around the just the
running of the program thank you second
question please second question is uh
who are these
facilitators and what as a training have
they had to be the facilitator sure so
um for many years we had just one
facilitator who was an experienced
special educator who had been in the
field for years and had retired however
we do also um provide them with
trainings nationally for IEP
facilitation so anytime there is
somebody from our TA Center or one of
the national organizations for dispute
resolution that puts out a facilitation
training we will pay for them to attend
that training um we now have two
facilitators and both of them have
either attended or are attending the IEP
facilitation trainings through these
technical assistance centers and many
and these technical assistance centers
are funded by the federal government
through oap to provide these services to
us thank you follow third follow one one
question yes pardon me yes go ahead
third question is can you define for us
what is the process I mean once you get
into this uh the the con the the
conversation around IAP placement and
services Etc what is the process that
first level we agree okay what so what's
the next level how what's the process
that a parent would go through to
finally get final resolution to what
their concerns are for their child so
the parents can um
before even getting to IEP facilitation
on the IEP they can say I agree in part
to the IEP and they can ask for the
district to address a an area that they
don't agree with um they can go to I the
parents can request this IEP
facilitation themselves they can go to
do process they can go to um complaints
so depending on what their issue is like
we encourage the districts to work with
them and if the parent doesn't agree for
something they should be having another
meeting to discuss the part that the
parent doesn't agree to there may just
be one piece to it I'd think that my
child needs three services for speech
instead of two and so I'll agree to
everything else to get the IEP in place
but then the district and the parents
should be meeting to discuss how they
can come to an agreement on that next
piece and if I don't agree what what's
my resolution so then if you don't agree
you can go to IEP facilitation you can
say the parent can request an IEP
facilitator or the district can request
the only caveat to either of those is
that both parties need to agree to it so
if the parent requests in the district
says no we wouldn't do it but if the
district requested and the parents said
no we wouldn't do it either um we also
will not do an IEP facilitation if
you're already in another dispute
resolution process so if you've already
gone to the complaints process or you've
gone to um mediation or due or due
process we don't want to go backwards
and put you into IEP facilitation we
need to let you do that through the the
regular process but you can ask for an
IEP facilitator and depending on what
your concern is you could go you could
take it even further to complaints thank
you uh represent Damon then thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my
question I have no expertise in this so
I'm looking at the current bill and a
bill we're hearing some time today 1443
about special ed dispute resolution that
talks about the process of neutral
conferences can you help me understand
the difference between the facilitation
in the neutral conference and what
overlap there might be between these two
bills that are in the same part of the
statute so I can explain to you the IEP
facilitation piece I would defer to my
colleague Diana Fenton or Steven Berwick
to clearly explain to you um neutral
conference just because I know the
generic piece of it but IEP facilitation
is in my office whereas dispute any of
the other dispute resolution processes
are in the office of governance um so
Diana oversees all of those IEP
facilitation is almost like the
precursor to all the other dispute
resolution processes it's like we're
having a agreement we can't get through
the meeting let's have somebody come in
and help us before we go to those other
dispute resolution processes so that's
and we run that through my office um
with one of our education consultants
and we assign the IEP facilitator
anything else Beyond this um IEP
facilitation goes into the office of
governance where it would be the state
complaint or the neutral conference or
mediation or due process follow yes so
just to clarify the facilitators that
you described in response to
representative Myer's question are not
the same people as the neutrals no thank
you representative Ford oh excuse me
representative Tanner had her hand up
first here thank you uh are there a list
of facilitators that how to how do
parents find a facilitator so on our
website um we assigned the facilitator
we only have two right now and so they
would go to the website um and there's a
link that you contact our education
consultant for the application and to um
apply for an IEP facilitator and it
depends on their availability and um and
I said as I said conflict of interest or
anything like that so we do assign them
it's not something you would reach out
to them directly it goes through our
office represent
Ford thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question is this process
made known to the parents from the
beginning so they understand they move
this step to that step to the next step
it just seems seems to me that an awful
lot of anxiety about this and and you
can understand why with the parents and
the students but I I'm just wondering
how do we facilitate their understanding
of it all y so we um share information
with the parent information center so
that we ensure that parents have know
about IEP facilitation we also have it
on our website and um we talk about it
anytime a parent calls and says I'm
having an issue or I have you know can
you help me with this we will suggest
whatever dispute resolution process we
think might help them um and we
recommend this on a regular basis would
you like to consider an IEP facilitator
it sounds like you're still in the
process where that might help you where
you are in this process does that seem
in do you have followup question
followup I'm sorry uh does that seem in
your experience to reduce somewhat the
confrontational aspect of it from what
we've heard from school districts and
parents yes it does um we actually have
had an increase in the last two years we
had had probably 23 from 20 2 to about
2023 and then in the last since July 1
of 2023 we've had 17 IEP facilitations
so it is in increase it is increasing
and from what we hear it is extremely
helpful on both sides from what we've
heard from the participants thank you
very much thank you are there any
further questions of the
department not seeing any oh yes
represent
Bon thank you Mr chair it's a quick one
um thank you for taking my
[Music]
question um there was a letter that came
from the sac committee that uh said that
they supported the bill but it says um
we respectfully request that it be
amended to State either party school or
parent maybe Crest an i AP facilitation
is that already I believe if you look I
don't have the um Statute in front of me
but if I believe if you look farther up
in RSA um c23 there it does say that
it's available to parents or
districts thank you further
questions thank you very much with that
yeah we we have previously gone ahead
and already sent to legislative Services
two amendments for the last Amendment
for each of the last Bills as soon as
those come back to us uh we intend to
exact those
bills y so and we
can't pardon me well well we will yeah
we we you know we'll we'll discuss that
and if there's you know a a common
ground there we will move forward with
them um so in the past we were would
have used this time to De deal with any
bills that previously been exact we
don't have that now in our rules doesn't
allow us to do it so we're sitting tight
here until
11:30
yes
yes well just go over and and hear it
because we're done that's closed
now
yep my presence is not needed for any
I'm not here if if we're going if we're
going to exact then it's going to be
with everybody agreeing So you you're so
I wouldn't need okay I just want to make
sure do you have to get out of here
right now not right now oh me no I don't
I can stay until lunch I can stay for
the next okay okay but I wouldn't if
you're doing any exacting this afternoon
I'm not I just wanted to no we will only
do exec if we get you know at least a
Direction but every opportunity we get
exec
e
the authorizing parents of special
education children to observe in
classroom
setting I'm going by the time zone in
the opposite room here you're sitting it
looks like it's 11:30 this one is 11:28
so we're going on the time zone in the
other other side of the room um
welcome
thank you Mr chair good morning
committee
members and guests thank you for having
me today I passed out two letters uh one
from my constituent Jamie Carter and one
is from the New Hampshire State advisory
committee on education and children and
students with disabilities uh they are
supporting this bill I just want you
guys to have those statements in
hand
uh I am representative Ron dun from
Londoner and I'm here today sponsoring a
bill that would allow special education
observation in the classro and allow
input from parents with
IEPs this issue was brought to my
attention by my constituent Jamie Carter
there is a letter you have in your hand
today after doing some research and
giving this issue some thought I saw the
importance of being here today and
presenting this issue to this
committee a parent of special needs
knows how challenging it is and
rewarding it can be for their child to
be involved in their
education there are many reasons why
this practice can have positive results
for both parents and children let me
share some with you today thank you
first they can help parents understand
their children's strengths challenges
and needs better by seeing how their
child interacts with the teacher and
other students parents can gain insight
into their child's learning style
preferences and goals this can help them
tailor their home environment activities
support and develop and learning it can
also help them communicate more
effectively with their
child second it can foster a positive
partnership between parents and teachers
by sharing information and feedback
parents and teachers can work together
to create individualized education
plans parents can also feel more
involved and supported in the
decision-making process this can lead to
a higher level of trust respect and
cooperation between parents and teachers
and this would benefit the child's
third by allowing parents to observe
classroom activities teachers can expose
children to special needs with different
perspectives cultures and experiences
this can help them develop social skills
empathy tolerance can also help them
feel more accepted
valued uh it can also boost their
self-confidence which can enhance their
learning and their
participation it can also enhance
academic outcomes for children with
special needs by observing classroom
instruction parents can learn about
effective strategies accommodations that
can help their child succeed in school
they also can provide encouragement
motivation for their child at home and
in the learning environment at
school as you can see by allowing
parents to observe in the classroom for
special need students can have many
positive effects for both the parents
the teachers and the child it can help
parents understand their child better
foster more positive partnership with
teachers and enhance academic outcomes
for the children I hope you agree with
me that this practice should be
encouraged and supported by schools and
policy makers thank you for your time
today if anyone has any questions I'd be
happy to answer them thank you very much
for your testimony are there questions
from the committee represent
Miler thank you Mr chair and thank you
for being here today uh we did receive
one of your handouts was from the
um the from from the committee and they
noted here
that they wanted it to be amended the
bill to be amended to remove the
statement School District shall impose
no conditions or restrictions what's
your uh response to that request I'm
absolutely fine with that whatever this
committee decides I'm fine with that
okay thank you further questions from
the committee represent Belcher thank
you Mr chair and following up on on that
exact point on that last one uh removing
uh the line on shall not impose
condition or restrictions obviously the
point of this bill is to be as open as
as possible I too see a problem with
obviously the possibility of imposing no
conditions because it could go
weird do you think there might be Middle
Ground such as school district shall
impose no unreasonable conditions or
restrictions something like that thank
you for the question absolutely thank
you foron
Damon I'm not sure if you're the person
to answer this question are one of the
technical experts
but what are the situations now for
parents who want to observe I mean I
know parents who have observed in
schools I've been
one I can ask you to refer to Jamie
Carter's letter and then I'll also defer
the question to the next person to
testify she would have much better
firsthand knowledge of that than I
would further questions yes Pres
cardelli thank you thank you
representative dun uh for bringing this
forward um having um uh observation
access by uh evaluators or
Consultants um would you see them coming
in with the parent or would you see them
um coming in independently or uh does it
make a
difference thank you for the question I
would say either option would
work further question
questions thank you very much thank you
I'd like to call Mariah
Ryan committee thank you um I'm here to
support hb1 1524 um I want to point out
in section 300.
310 um of federal code it says that all
public agencies must ensure that a child
is able to be observed in the child's
learning environment um and that this
would support that um to your point uh
the courts have said that um essentially
school districts cannot impose
unreasonable conditions um but they can
request the confidentiality agreement so
the court felt that confidentiality
agreements to not discuss other students
would be okay but a parent can obviously
give permission to um talk about their
own kid um as for my own experience with
uh trying to get get classroom
observations from my son who has autism
I had to fight with the school for 2
years when I finally was able to get an
observation in place I was glad I did
get the observation because I found that
the the school district had put my son
in the corner with two special education
teachers around him and I said we can't
do that because he can't concentrate on
a lesson and have two people next to him
talking to him
simultaneously um there are plenty of
other parents who have gone into
classrooms or had Specialists go into
classrooms to get data to evaluate
whether or not an IEP is working
um to determine whether or not fape is
being provided if a parent is denied an
opportunity to observe in the classroom
the court has unilaterally said that as
a denial of fatee automatically so um
this came about via various coure cases
Schaefer versus whis is one of them but
as Jamie had stated in her testimony to
you the state of Massachusetts actually
put this in as a law because it has to
be parents have to be able to get data
on whether or not their kids' education
is working so
it is an imperative component of this
and I think if a school district wants
to have some sort of restrictions if
they work with the parent I think the
parent would be amenable because all the
parent really wants is to have their kid
get the the appropriate education or the
you know the best situation possible for
them um with that in mind um I'm kind of
pressed for time so I'd like to just
start taking questions if that's
possible that's fine I have one for you
uh you you mentioned confidentiality and
unreasonable uh
as a adjective for talking about uh
imposing conditions Etc or restrictions
yes sir uh can you give me some examples
of what would be
unreasonable um you can't observe unless
a special education director is there
we'll only give you 20 minutes of time
you can't have a professional come in
and observe um will'll only allow you to
observe during gym class uh those would
be examples of unreasonable and those
were specifically stated by the court
sir thank you further questions from the
committee
yes represent Celli thank you thank you
for your testimony um when you um say
they were indicated by the courts are
you referring to schaer versus whis in
that regard or other cases schaer versus
whis is one of the cases and but that
case in particular was a Massachusetts
case in the federal doe due process and
committee further
questions thank you very much thank you
berson
welcome good morning my name is Jane
berson bullu I'm the executive director
of the special ed administrators I'm
here representing over 270 members of
our association um who work in both
public schools and our private special
education schools I'm here representing
the association we're not taking a
stance on the bill but um our members
did um ask that I bring forward some
comments uh for your
consideration upon a review of the bill
um our Association members really felt
as though um locally um every district
has policy related to visitors uh to
schools and observations in classrooms
um and as our members reviewed this bill
they felt as though um bringing forward
uh more legislation um really wasn't
necessary at this point and that school
districts pretty much um had policy even
we checked in with our private special
education schools and they also have uh
developed policies on this topic uh
relative to visitors and observations in
classrooms and that includes everything
from safety to security to
confidentiality and and those kinds of
things so we really felt as though um
more legislation probably was not
necessary and that it should be left to
the local
level um additionally um in terms of the
the language in this bill it calls for
allowing independent
evaluators uh to observe in classrooms
um that currently happens um it's very
common for school districts and parents
to uh be getting independent evaluators
um to come in observe kids conduct
evaluations um and there are protocols
and processes that are already in place
and it it seems to be a a pretty uh
common practice in in talking with our
members um the other comments that that
our members brought forward was that the
language in the bill really um moves
more towards giving very uh unrestricted
unlimited um amounts of times in
programs and we all know whether it be a
special education program or General Ed
program um having um unlimited time for
visitors can be very dis you know um
distracting disruptive um and they're
really needs to be um some guard rails
around that and and this bill really
seemed to be pretty br
um those were the the comments uh that
our members brought forward and wanted
me to bring to your attention um and we
would ask that maybe you consider those
before uh moving the bill forward in uh
the process so thank you for your time
thank you very much I do have a question
for you I'll start out you talked about
independent uh
evaluators uh in the
classroom and there are protocols for
that uh are those protocols based upon
any policy statements that have been
designed either by your organization or
by the school boards Association so we
have consistency throughout the
state um you know we've got one of our
members who can you give you more
details and talking with our members yes
they felt as though their school boards
had developed policy on this topic and
provided them with great guidance and
guidelines um for these kinds of
situations
and as I mentioned our independent
evaluators um in in the world of special
education parents hire them districts
hire them they're essential to bringing
their expertise to assessing kids
observing kids giving recommendations
and consultation on um best practice and
input to IEPs and those kinds of
things thank you represent dry thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question um in a previous hearing we
heard about a process that was going on
um without statute uh behind it and they
asked for the statute to back it up so
I'm kind of confused as to whether you
know it's nice to have policies with
statutes behind it or or operating
without them um and I'm wondering why it
wouldn't be a good idea to put a statute
behind
it you know I would defer that to the
school boards Association I'm not an
expert um in that area so I
wouldn't I wouldn't want to comment I'm
not quite
sure we were just basically looking at
the bill and the
language represent Miler thank you Mr
chair and thank you for being here
um I'm a parent and I just had an IEP
that we agreed
to what are my rights as a
parent to go through to make sure that
the IEP is in fact being implemented as
we agree to can you can you kind of walk
us through from a parent
perspective what that means I'm new to
this never had it before I'm glad I have
some services but I don't really know
what my role is can you outline it from
a standpoint from your professional
experience certainly the parents are
absolutely essential and intrical to the
IEP process um their input should be
provided all along the way in the
development even before the I team
begins even before the development of an
IEP begins it's so important to help
parents understand um one the kind of
disability their child has two what to
expect going through the special ed
process um and then by the time you get
down to you know look at the assessments
that are done being able to explain
those assessments to parents in
userfriendly
terms and how we're going to use that
information to set some goals um and
what kinds of specially designed
instruction will your child need based
on their
disability um and then how are we going
to measure that um and I think when you
when you look at Ida it it says parents
must be an essential part of the IE team
they should be given reasonable
opportunities to observe their child's
and any um any any potential placement
that they might be in um and I think our
school districts are doing a great job
of giving that reasonable opportunity
obviously there's going to be times when
uh conflict arises and and schools may
not disagree they may disagree um but
for the most part in in talking with our
members and our private schools and our
Public Schools they really felt as
though those processes were in
place um
so if thank you for that explanation so
if a parent though does have a
disagreement with the axis based upon
the plan and as you've outlined if a
parent has a disagreement with access to
the classroom what is the process for
appeal that a parent might go through to
gain greater access to the classroom my
understanding it would be would be the
same as any other policy going to the
the principal the superintendent school
board and working through it that way
thank you uh representative
cordelli um thank you
um uh I remember distinctly um a hearing
um I believe it was down in the Senate
um a floor below us um with a specialed
parent who was a lawyer
but was having trouble navigating the
process that we just talked
about um do you believe that the process
is clearly laid out for parents um in a
guide a pamphlet in some kind of
material that is made available to
them I think the process is laid out
very clearly it's not easy to understand
and I think districts do that in a
variety of ways with a variety of
Partners the parent information center
um we are always sending out information
to our members to distribute um to
parents via the special eded Min the um
parent information center um many of our
districts have parent groups that
support one another you know that are
coordinated with the district to help
parents par s understand the process and
um helping to educate them and support
them it it's difficult enough to have a
child with AB disability but to
understand all the timelines and
paperwork and signatures it it can be
overwhelming um and I think we can
always do better um that you know it's
not it's not perfect but the process is
clearly outlined yeah go ahead um thank
you um in the proc process um I know
that there is a a special education
database and I cannot remember the
acronym I too many yes right yes um
thank you um do you think that the
process and
tracking of a child through the process
is accurately captured um and data is
available on track tracking a child
database you know I'm not a current user
of the nessus system and nessus is the
New Hampshire special education
information system and that's where all
of the Special Education data is
stored um I think districts and our
private special education schools do a
great job on uh collecting data as
related to student ress and their
reports and that's typically done in a
variety of different ways um nesus is is
one place to store your progress report
um but I think most of our school
systems have pretty robust uh ways in
which they're tracking kids uh progress
in a variety of different ways as we all
know we don't do that with just one
assessment and often time it's kind of
especially with kids with disabilities
it's benchmarking along the way and many
of them are involved with some pretty
specialized um types of Assessments
whether it be a specialized reading
program which wouldn't be in nessus or
you know specialized behavioral
intervention interventions which
wouldn't be a nessus so um you know I
think ness's is fine in terms of the
basic kind of Statewide data but in
terms of Rich robust student progress
that probably wouldn't be the system to
find that kind of
information further questions represent
Tanner thank you and thank you for
taking my question with inclusion these
students are often in uh the larger
classroom area it's not not just the
resource area or uh special ed room I
mean that
that's doesn't happen a lot anymore um
and so the school policy uh it seems to
me that the one for special Edge
shouldn't override the school policy for
someone who's a parent in a regular Ed
classroom uh from should be similar or
the same uh is that true that would be
my understanding and again we've got one
of our members who can speak
specifically but you know my
understanding is that there are policies
related to school visitors and classroom
observations and that's for all
kids um and that we you know special ed
kids are General Ed kids and as you said
they're in many kids are in the General
Ed setting for the vast majority of
their day um and many times their
special education services are provided
in the General Ed classroom um so my
understanding is that it is a policy
connected to all
kids are would you believe there should
be exceptions to that for example I had
a school where we frowned on parents
coming in the first several week or so
of kindergarten often times that was
very difficult for the kindergarten
teacher have mother or father sitting
there and and we also had a policy where
you don't come in during testing week um
uh we there's a number of like policies
but we also saw do you believe that
there should be some exceptions to the
school district policy to allow for
example a parent to come in who has a
child that's uh handicapped maybe during
that first week of school while that
child's in can
I think those kinds of things I mean if
there needs to be something built into
an IEP specific for one child yeah that
can certainly be done that's that's what
I wanted to hear thank you represent
leus thank you thank you for taking my
question um you were talking about one
of your objections which I understand
that parents coming in can actually be
disruptive if they are there a long time
Etc and I'm wondering if the phrase in
here
um except where it says um they can't
impose conditions or restrictions except
those necessary to ensure the and it
says Integrity of the program and I'm
wondering if Integrity of the program
would cover those conditions so that a
parent couldn't come and be you know be
there so long as to be disruptive or Etc
do you think does that
work could did you restate the question
I'm sorry I know it's and do you have
the bill in front of you no I don't okay
so it's the section that talks about um
School District shall impose no
conditions or restrictions on such
observations except those necessary too
and then it has a list of things and one
of the things is integrity of the
use the IDE a that um the Integrity of
the program can't be disrupted and I'm
wondering if you think that phrase would
cover those
instances where having the parents there
too much or too long or whatever at the
wrong times would be
disruptive yeah I I think that term
covers that definitely okay thank you
are there further questions from the
committee not seeing any hands thank you
very much thank you I'd like to invite
bigford hello uh my name is Jessica
Bickford um I fill a couple of different
roles I am a parent of a child with
special needs but I am also a assistant
superintendent for sau53 public
schools um much of what I have to say is
similar to what uh Jane had just said
not necessarily for or against in
particular but just I would like you to
have careful consideration of some of
the language that's in the bill um I
would like to reiterate that many
schools already have policies that cover
visitors and those kind of things to the
school to the classroom setting to
programs after school programs those
kinds of things so just consideration
that it might be a bill that may not be
needed or consideration to expand Beyond
just special education because this bill
just covers special education and I'm
wondering why it might only cover
special education and not general
education which would Encompass special
education um it does raise some concerns
around potential furpa violations for
other students in special programs so if
a parent is coming into observe a
special program there may very well be
other students in that program who have
severe disabilities medical issues
sensitive things that they have to deal
with that are part of their own program
during the school day and that parent
may not necessarily have the right to
observe or have any knowledge about that
child um during that same time so just
consideration of that as well
um there are mechanism in place through
the IEP team process that would allow
parent to have some of this information
or the team could develop a plan for the
parent to come in and do some of those
kind of observations there's also uh
procedures involved for outside agencies
or evaluators to come in and observe
students and their programs and collect
data that will be used for IEP
development and program development um
and I just would like to say that I I I
think it's because we're in the business
of people in education you're going to
have different performances no matter
where you go throughout the state I
personally have had parents come into my
classroom when I was a teacher without a
problem um but it was on good terms we
had a good relationship and I think some
of the language in this bill appears to
have an
adversarial context to the language so I
just caution that um because it does
come across as being a friendly
good-natured open door kind of policy
which I think was the intent from the
hearing uh the testimony that was given
but I don't know that it comes across
that way um so just caution with that as
well thank you very much are there any
questions from the committee
representative
perinel thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question in regards to
furpa violations if I look on P line 14
of the bill I don't know if you have it
in front of you but it says
um let's see school districts shall
impose no conditions and then we move
down to line 14 where it says um protect
the children in the program from
Disclosure by an observer of
confidential and personally identifiable
information in the rulle making process
wouldn't it be possible to require a
parent to sign some form saying they
would not disclose in anything that they
saw or observed but I think we may have
to be in a position where we get
permission from that other parent as
well to allow that disclosure of
personal information because their their
child's rights would be violated um we
also can't control what people say even
though they sign a non-disclosure
agreement or that a privacy agreement of
some sort they also have to adhere to
those kind of um standards when we go
through due process as well however it's
not very often followed and we have no
recourse as a school to hold that parent
accountable or who whoever it might be a
visitor or provider um accountable if
personal information is shared out y
thank you further further questions
represent cordelli thank you thank you
for being here um uh it's been mentioned
that uh districts have observation
policies in place most districts let's
say um isn't it possible though that
those um General observation policies um
might restrict
observation to the
parent and not include for a uh an
independent evaluator or consultant and
thus the need for some specific um
statuto language to allow those people
as
well I mean I guess it could be it would
depend on the school district's policy I
don't there's no mandate for us to have
that kind of policy in place which might
be what you're kind of alluding to um we
don't have anything saying that we have
to have or welcome visitors to come in
and observe those things I think schools
choose to do that to cover the that
opportunity or that instance when that
might happen um I know there's a lot of
schools that have eval outside
evaluators or Consultants come in on a
regular basis um I think it's usually
done in collaboration with the teachers
union with the administration of that
building so that there is a an agreed
upon and of positive out Outlook from
the beginning right it's not coming in
as a gotcha or trying to um find
something wrong with a program or a
teacher in general so I think there is
the possibility for you know it might be
a sound reason to have some legislation
that says we have to have a policy
around this but I just would encourage
you to kind of take into consideration
all those factors that play into that um
and the privacy of kids and is it the
program we're evaluating or the teacher
that's being evaluated and delivering
that program because those are two
separate things thank you further
question represent
leus um you mentioned that it seemed to
have an adversarial feel and the that
would the question is would you be
willing to um make suggestions as how to
change the wording so that it is more
friendly your open feelings sure I I
certainly wouldn't mind helping um
reward some things if you know I felt
like
the I guess I agreed or if it was
expanded to more than just special ed
right I think that's kind of my barrier
in this is it's it's just targeting
special education and not all students
um and I understand the intent like I
said I I understand the testimony that
was given in why the bill came forward
um and it's unfortunate that a parent
had to go through that kind of situation
when clearly there was a bad
relationship involved which may have
been the initiating factor for all of
that um which is really unfortunate um
but yeah I would be happy to help with
word smithing or you know putting it in
a more positive light Absol thank you
very much I I do have a question then
represent beler um as previous teacher
principal administrator
myself our schools had this already in
place so is this legislation
necessary and that's my word of
consideration and caution is that I
think it might be redundant I think
there are already many schools that have
these kind of policies in place however
I don't know that we are forced to have
them in place so I get the there was
some comments made earlier around should
we have legislation if we have that
expectation so I could see why there
might want to be some legislations
legislation saying schools have to have
a policy um but I would just encourage
that maybe we could expand that and not
have it be pigeon hold into special
education thank you represent
beler thank you Mr chair and thank you
for your testimony I just wanted to
follow up on on the uh the regular
classroom versus the special ed portion
of of that because certainly I don't I
don't inherently see any problem with
parents being able to observe a regular
classroom
either but given the inherent
vulnerabilities in special education
students does it not make some degree of
sense that parents might have a greater
interest in that population in observing
them um absolutely because there there
are unique programming and it's very
individualized and so and and they may
very well provide fantastic input on why
maybe a team is struggling with student
progress or maybe there's an issue going
on that they are very key Partners in
helping solve um I am in no way against
family participation in that and
observation I think I would just not
want it to be only representative of
special education because there is Great
Value in having parent presence and
Community presence in the school
buildings that I think is uh potentially
underutilized and underappreciated I
think it's a really good thing to have a
positive and open relationship with your
parents and community members um but yes
there there would be a vested um
opportunity and great opportunity missed
if parents weren't involved in those
specialty programs for
sure thank you very much further
questions representative Tanner thank
you thank you for taking my question I
would think that it would be important
um I know from a from a teacher's aspect
be important to kind of set up the
visitation beforehand um and it seems
like with no restriction or conditions
uh the person could show up at the
schoolhouse door and say I demand to be
in class X Y and Z or whatever is that
do you see that is a problem with this
no conditions or
restrictions I mean it could um um I
think the the bill as written also
allows the opportunity for the school
district to create their own policy
around it so the school district could
create the policy that says has to be
pre-arranged you know no it could be
three days in advance or something um
and I don't think that that would be
unreasonable I think there's similar um
language that's embedded into the idea
around
um you know advanced notice of things
like advanced notice of meetings you
know we have so many hour or days um or
weeks to respond to certain things and I
think that would this would kind of be
open to a similar lens um so I'm not
necessarily worried or concerned about
that because the school district may
very well build that into a policy that
they create thank you further questions
thank you very much yes thank you um I'd
like to invite up before we go to the
department uh Becky fet not excuse me
Becky
Association and I I do have a question
for
you um does the school boards
Association this bill speaks about
District shall develop policies allowing
classroom BL does the the school boards
Association have policies for that I
know that you're you have a strong
background in special education so maybe
you can help us out well thank thank you
for the question and thank you for um
offering me that opportunity the school
boards Association does have a number of
policies and I think it might have been
last session or the session previous
where we had a lengthy discussion uh at
this committee about uh policies that
are already uh available for school
districts in terms of visitor policies
observation policies surveillance video
recording Etc um there's also policies
around special education evaluation in
listening to people talk a little bit um
about this bill it I'm a little confused
about the Catalyst for this bill whether
it is wanting observation to assess uh
whether or not a student is making
adequate progress in their program or
whether it is part of an
eligibility observation process um there
are policies already about observations
as part of the special ed eligibility
process um there are certain evaluators
in New Hampshire statute for special
education evaluation who are um
appropriate or allowed to complete the
observation process as part of a
student's eligibility evaluation all of
those things would be determined during
the evaluation process in terms of who's
doing the observation what their
qualifications are Etc um there are as I
said multiple recommended policies in
terms of observation video visitor
policies uh
Etc the school district also does have
to uphold furpa as I think many people
have said before me uh in terms of these
processes uh the non-disclosure comment
I don't there's no policy for that
specifically I think uh to the previous
speaker's point it would be difficult
for a school to ensure that if a person
is following a student for a length of
time during the day that that would be
very difficult to ensure that other
students privacies uh are protected and
those are not recommended options for
schools to do they are required to
uphold student PR y um and that includes
for outside observers Etc but yes there
are policies for those things do we have
access to are these on the web these
policies to speak to or do we have to um
I can give them to you again I'm pretty
sure um we can pull them from last
year's or the year before policies um in
terms of that and I also just um want to
be clear that um parent training for
example parent participation in the IEP
process is very high I in terms of the
bar uh in New Hampshire in most
districts in terms of ensuring that
parents have the opportunity to
participate in the development of all of
this um and being able to vet out
whether a child is making appropriate
progress again the language in this bill
is confusing because effective progress
is not used anywhere in special ed
language in the state it's appropriate
or adequate in light of the child's
unique circumstances that's not anywhere
in this bill um so it's a little
confusing about whether the intent of
the bill is to provide observation
opportunities to assess a child's
progress or whether or not the program
is appropriate for the student or
whether it is to provide opportunities
for training for parents and schools to
work collaboratively to make sure
there's a good carryover between home
and school um with any uh interventions
that are happening for a particular
student thank you are there any other
questions representative Milo thank you
Mr chair and thank you for clarifying
these issues I want you to put sure sped
hat on for a moment um because I think
the issue once a parent enters into an
understanding of an IEP there is an
obvious concern about what happens to
their child in the special
programs throughout the once the program
is instituted what is the reporting
process what how does a
parent understand whether or not the
intervention and the program that's been
created for my child is is working what
what's what's the feedback loop how how
am I engaged as a parent in this process
thank you for the question um built into
every IEP is a section under every
single goal in terms of how progress
will be reported to the parent and how
frequently progress will be reported to
the parent that is different depending
on the student and depending on the
student's program it's not uncommon for
schools and families who have a strong
relationship to set up for examp this is
an example it's not a requirement a
monthly progress meeting with the IEP
team to sit down and go over what's
happened over the past month and talk
about what is working and what is not
working um it's not uncommon for those
progress reports have to go out to
parents at least as frequently as
progress is reported to other parents
who are not parents of children with
special needs so for example if your
report card is on a trimester system you
have to report out IEP progress goals at
least trimester is that a word um or
quarter you know if you give a report
card every quarter you have to provide
progress reports on the students IEP
goals and objectives at least every
quarter you cannot provide less than
what you provide to other students
parents thank you you're welcome further
questions representative P now thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question in regards to preventing fura
violations what would you do
with just an average typical parent
volunteer just coming into the class
room because they could easily go back
out into the community and disclose any
situation Behavior student information
they wanted and do they um sign a
non-disclosure before they volunteer in
the classroom thank you for the question
um what constitutes a designated
volunteer is a local decision at the at
the local school board level they often
that needs to be defined for things like
criminal background checks as you know
designated volunteers require background
check for certain situations um the
difference with those situations might
be a couple of things one the intent of
this bill seems to be directed
specifically at looking at a student's
special education programming so I think
it just lends itself to believe that the
fact is that they would be whoever is
observing would have access to knowing
that they are observing a special
education program versus observing the
day-to-day ongoings of the school the
second piece is that because designated
volunteers are identified at the local
level in terms of what that means you
are as an administrator deciding what
situations are appropriate for a
designated volunteer to be a part of
you're not just allowing a person to
necessarily follow a particular student
around for the day so you would be able
to set up the situation where hopefully
you are setting that up so that it's
protective of all the students in terms
of people's provision of services it's
not that you will never see anything I
mean you could certainly be in a school
for any number of reasons and see a
child is having a behavior challenge and
how that is a dealt with can you protect
that parent from going out into the
community no but to the point previously
that I think somebody brought up about
stories um of parents and I want to be
sensitive to this parents who are
willing to come to these committees and
share their challenges and um
experiences with their own children at
the school district level they can share
those experiences because they are the
parent the school district even if we're
sitting behind the parent that's EXP
explaining this has no ability to
provide any context for that situation
or provide any other information about
why the parent is has had that
experience from a different perspective
possibly because of fura so again the
parents are disclosing those things um
on their own it has nothing to do with
the school sort of setting up the
situation where that would be uh a
violation of the school's ability to
maintain the students
confidentiality thank you further
questions yes representative uh dry and
then represent
leus thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question the you had a few
minutes ago a a list of policies that
you could use as templates right um do
any of those have like a stat to backing
that there behind them uh thank you for
the
question there are some statutory
restrictions in terms of video
recordings and things like that which I
think I mentioned because in some
situations should a parent want to see
something that is happening in a
particular situation where inperson
observation wouldn't be appropriate you
could certainly record certain things
and the district could maintain so there
are statutes behind recordings when
recordings can be used um I'm just
trying to look quickly at some of the
samples um the evaluation process for
special education obviously has statutes
behind it of which observation is a
required aspect of specialed Eligibility
um who doing the observation again all
of those things are vetted out in the
specialed process if you have an
observation and a family has an outside
evaluator that they want to come in to
observe that person's title name
qualifications is part of the evaluation
determination process you already know
that person is coming and the district
is working with them to make sure that
they're coming at a time that's going to
allow them to assess whatever the
question is that they're trying to
resolve so yes some of them do have
statutory backing
yes
represent thank
you thank you for answering my question
um you had said instead of effective
progress you gave two terms one was
adequate and I didn't get the other one
thank you for the question uh I I
believe what I probably said was
appropriate in light of the child's
unique circumstances which is the
special ed law thank you you're welcome
further questions thank you very much
thank you could you get those sample
policies to Jennifer 4 and then she can
send them out to us thank
you uh
department hello thank you for taking my
um testimony that we are not taking a
stance on this bill at all um I am just
wanted to provide some technical
assistance regarding a letter that was
put out by the federal office of special
education programs regarding
observations in the classroom um in May
26th of 2004 there was a letter which I
will share with the committee um we
recently came upon it that discusses it
came from the education Law Center and
they asked oep to provide an opinion on
whether the individuals with Disability
Act guarantees parents and their
representatives a reasonable opportunity
to observe in their children's
classrooms and proposed placement
options um and there's some really good
information in here I think will be
helpful to you but the one paragraph
that I think um I just want to share is
that while Ida expects parents of
children with disabilities to have an
expanded role in the evaluation and
educational placement of their children
and be participants along with school
Personnel in developing reviewing and
revising IEPs for their children neither
the statute nor the regulations
implementing the idea provide a general
entitlement for parents of children with
disabilities or their professional
representatives to observe their
children in any current classroom or
proposed educational place
they do go on to say that they suggest
that districts and parents collaborate
together so that things like that can be
done um and under certain circumstances
and when they have an independent
evaluation that that would be allowed so
I we I just wanted to share that
information with you and we will share
that letter with you thank you any
questions of the
department thank you very much we have
no more pink cards on this so we're
going to close the hearing for 1524
could I make an announcement about this
cards
yeah go ahead um I would just like to
mention um as we break for lunch that uh
this is national school choice week um
in the office there are yellow school
choice scarves for for everybody
including anyone in the audience who
would like
one thank you so we will break and we
o'clock
e
us uh hearings which we have the first
hearing up is
159 that's prohibiting spending of
special education monies for any other
purpose and requiring reporting of fund
balances to the school board I'd like to
welcome uh represent Kevin
chairman short and simple bill on there
we go this is a short and simple bill as
I'm sure you are all aware School
District budgets are bottom line budgets
and monies can be moved from one line to
another to uh meet the changing needs of
the school district as the budget year
progresses
on one of the challenges especially for
Budget committees and and citizens and
taxpayers is transparency on special
education budgets and that's largely
driven by uh Privacy Law privacy
considerations which I completely agree
with and completely
respect and so what this bill aims to do
is to take the special ed money that's
approved within a School District budget
and lock it into special education use
so if the money is ear marked for
special education that's what it can be
used for and it cannot be transferred
out into regular
education or other line items in in the
in the budget and I I think that this
would be a a good bill it also requires
that the district report what their
special ed fund balance is at the at the
end of the year
so that taxpayers and others can um see
how that compares to the overall
budget that's all I have great wonderful
uh are there any questions of the
representative yes representative
cordelli uh thank you representative for
bringing this uh this afternoon um when
you're talking about sh report annually
are you talking about that that should
be included in their annual
report yes yeah so long so long as the
information is made readily available
publicly uh the form doesn't really
matter too much to me so long as it's
requestable and easy to
get further questions from the
committee not seeing any hands up in the
air thank you very much thank you so
Bickford
hello thank you Jessica Bickford uh
again sa53 assistant superintendent
student services are you uh representing
yourself or I'm representing myself yes
okay that should be in the record too y
thank you um I oppose this bill um as
school districts already have mechanisms
in place to report out expenditures and
costs in each of their budget lines so
at the at many points during a school
year a school board will ask for
expenditure
reports and for end of your reports that
show in
detail what monies are left in each of
the lines and that include special
education so as the year goes on school
boards are well aware of what monies are
currently in their lines what monies are
expected to be expended and then what
money are expected to be left over or
reserved at the end of the
year um if there were questions and how
much money were those would be uh left
in the budget there's already processes
in place to address that through the
typical Schoolboard process um spending
is only done and Allowed by line and uh
allocation and description in those
lines so when we have a purchase order
come in we have to make sure that that
activity matches the description Within
that line to be spent as it is
um line balances have to be reported by
October 1 already so I think that's
redundant information there's already
processes in place school districts
already have to report out what was
spent what wasn't spent and that has to
go into public reports as it already
stands thank you are there any questions
from the
committee yes representative cordelli
thank you um when you say that this is
reported out October 1st um who is it
reported out to because I think um as I
see it the intent of this that is that
uh this information would be readily
available to citizens of the
district so a variety of different ways
so typically by the time June July rolls
around at the end of a school year that
information is publicly already
distributed through the school SCH board
meeting process so typically at a school
board meeting we would publicly discuss
what's left in each of the fund lines
because they get an end ofe report so
that information is already made public
in public minutes um documents things
like that through the Schoolboard
process and of your reports have those
line descriptions and amounts that are
left over or that are overe expended or
if there had to be line transfers or
future line transfers um there would be
entries in that that would show why that
had to be done um and if questions were
arose the board would have an
opportunity to ask or push back or say
yes or no on those things um the forms
that are submitted in the fall of the
following year of a fiscal year um those
are the forms that are reported to our
our banks our trusts things like that we
have to submit Ms forms like the ms25
ms27 those are all forms that are
submitted um by rules that aren't
necessarily submitted into a public
record Forum but they are public records
anyone can ask for those
items thank you y uh just some clarifica
clarification here for
myself we're operating on a fiscal
year and are we talking October 1
following the fiscal year um and if not
how are we accounting for encumbered
Monies so that was a question that um
thank you that was a question that came
up as I was reading this as well is I'm
not sure the language in the proposed
Bill clarifies if it's the current
fiscal year or the following fiscal year
um so typically it would be the previous
fiscal year that you're reporting out um
from in the fall so this year's school
budget operating budget
2324 would be reported out in summer and
fall of the next fiscal school year um
so it gets kind of confusing and I
wasn't clear from the bill whether they
wanted projections from the current
school year budget or if it was a
wrap-up from the previous School Year's
budget thank you further forur the
questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you very
much thank you uh next card we have on
a um members of the committee thank you
for calling me up I'm just here to
provide uh any technical assistance for
it to be needed about how these monies
are already reported upon are there any
questions for the Schoolboard
association yes represent D
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question
so the bill was introduced saying
um that it would prohibit money in
special education line items from being
used for any other
purpose and the second speaker just said
you already can't spend money in a
different category so could you said
some light on the
current law thank you for the question I
mean the school boards Association would
be opposed to this language as it is
presented currently um again your line
item budget is approved by
your voters uh the school board
obviously is able to transfer make line
item transfers as needed those are all
approved at school board meetings which
are public meetings the Manifest is
signed off on um on a regular basis by a
school board member that is um
designated to sign off on your manifest
so you would know where monies are
moving around to and from um a line item
budget to be recalculated and pushed out
publicly that information is available
to the public public as part of the
school board packet the majority of the
time if people want to look at that um
it's also a little concerning because
I'm not clear based on this bill what
would happen how do you account for um
services or instructional materials or
trainings that
influence many students or teachers in a
district that are not solely in your
1200 lines which are your special
edlines things like um training for
regular education teachers in terms of
you know working with students with
special needs or particular areas
equipment building changes Etc that
would need to be taken into account that
may not necessarily just be under your
1200 lines I'm not sure what situation
is the Catalyst for this particular
language or whether there's a concern
that there's specialed money that's not
being expended typically we don't see
that problem it's usually the reverse
that there's not enough special ed money
to expend so I don't know of many
situations where this has happened thank
you thank you further further questions
yes representative Cornell Thank you
thank you for taking my question um it
sounds like what you're talking about
are places that that vote directly on
school budgets by the constituents what
happens in a place like Manchester
that's giving a School District budget
thank you for the question that's that
is a very good question um I would Point
your local board school committee back
to their general counsel in terms of how
they would account for monies that needs
to be switched around or something to
that effect um that wouldn't already be
subject to some sort of public meeting
or some other way to account for where
that money is going um there are
procedures for that in both cities and
in towns that are on the local vote so
I'm not sure I'm not again I no
disrespect to the sponsors of this bill
I'm not sure what the pro what problem
this bill is trying to address or what
the concern is that was brought forth in
terms of money being unexpended for
special ed or being taken from Special
Ed and put somewhere else further
questions thank you very much thank you
uh we have a card also from uh Jan Bon
Association good afternoon and thank you
for the opportunity to
testify for the record my name is Jam
Bon bullu and I'm the executive director
for the special ed administrators
Association and I won't repeat um any of
the previous uh testimony that you heard
but our association I'm here
representing our association and we're
in opposition of this bill um the basis
of the OB objection is really that our
members um can demonstrate and feel as
though um within their school districts
there are well- defined processes in
place uh for um budgeting monitoring
funds as well as Any Grant monies that
come in it's very highly regulated and
well documented um and felt as though
that this bill wasn't necessary I think
our biggest concern was that the bill
you know refers to um only using special
education money uh for special education
situations and as we spoke um earlier
today um most of our special ed students
are in the general education setting and
our members felt as though this bill
could really po potentially negatively
impact inclusionary practices um idea
allows for preventative uh interventions
in the General Ed setting um which is
where many of those kinds of
interventions happen and they often
include general education students so
for example if a speech and language
pathologist is working um on language
skills with um a student um who might
have an IEP they could be in a small
group setting with General ed students
and so the monies are used um for that
speech pathologist to pay for the
implementation of the IEP but typical
students are engaged in the small group
and have to be so that the student can
socialize and use their language
skills um in addition to that you know
some other examples are many of our
school districts are using specialized
literacy programs such as Orton
Gillingham just an example um oftentimes
that's used and paid for through special
ed money but is used for um all kids um
if there are interventions out there
that work um we might as well use them
for all students we also talked in our
association a lot about um response to
interventions and multi-tiered systems
of support which are being highly
encouraged and supported in all of our
public schools and these are um you know
layers of interventions um and they are
intended to be for all kids including um
our most needy who might be in the top
tier um but within that top tier here
you know special ed might be funding a
lot of those interventions but there
would be General Ed kids also engaged in
those
opportunities so in conclusion we felt
as though that the bill as written um
really could have some negative impacts
Upon Our um entire school systems as it
relates to both General and special
education students and hope that you
would consider this testimony thank you
very much thank you very much uh
representative dry thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question um I I
like your example of using a mixed group
of students for um uh a process uh but I
I think the intent would be special
education I mean it's not like this is a
special education person joining a
different group it would be used to for
the special education process so I don't
see exactly how that would be not uh it
would be money that was not spent on
special
education well I guess that's the the
lack of clarity within the bill itself
you know it it's speaks of um
prohibiting the use of special education
monies for anything other than special
education um and so that's an example
where it's not just special education
and it happens often so if you use you
know the example of multi-tiered systems
of support the first tier is uh making
sure that all kids have access to
interventions and it could be that in
tier one one we've got several kids with
disabilities who need a specific
intervention and you've got a teacher in
there and you've got three kids if you
can take for General Ed kids at the same
time and they all work together and can
benefit it's coste effective and it's
the most beneficial thing for the child
so you're you're using some of that
money for General Ed and special ed does
that helped to clarify follow yes a
little bit but I I think my just in my
mind it would it would be adding to a
special education process not taking it
as a a non specialed process and adding
special ed to it um I think I'm looking
at it that direction um can you help me
sure so it would be spe um probably um
budgeted in the special ed budget for
those intervention and that
interventionist um so you know it
they're not just
limiting it to special ed kits and and
we felt as though as this bill was
written these fund it was stating that
special ed money should go just to
special
education thank you are there further
questions represent
Belcher thank you Mr chair and thank you
for that enlightening testimony um we
often hear in this committee that we are
not adequately funding special education
there's not enough money for what needs
to be done um I just want to clarify
that your testimony is that we're
actually expending special education
funds on special education services that
are being applied generally and not just
to special education students they're
being applied to special education
students and if there's an opportunity
to bring in kids other kids typical kids
that would benefit it's not going to
cost anymore I mean why do it for two
kids when you might be able to do it for
five and hopefully um that would would
you know delay or not delay but not
cause a student to be referred to
special education so if they can get you
know have advantage of those
interventions um why not provide it to
all does that
help it does and if I may just just to
clarify then so there there are no
circumstances occurring where special
education funds are being expended for
special education services without
regard for the special education service
or the the special education child being
present or not so there's no just
blanket administration of these kind of
services without at least knowing that
there is a special education child
present who's benefiting from this
service I would say no that's not the
all you look like you're questioning S I
I I think I may have reversed that that
question answer so okay why don't you
pursue it just thank you just the
so there
are are there ever occasions happening
where we are spending special education
funds and utilizing special education
services wherein there may not be a
special education child present
receiving them no typically if the the
special education student is not there
the um special educator would go on to
the next kids on her case list and
adjust her scheduled um that kind of
thing thank
you are the further questions
for uh special uh Association not see it
thank you very much thank
you are there any other cards for this
particular Bill to
coming okay bring it up no no just hand
it
there thank you Miss Ryan welcome back
I'm sorry I just directly need to rebut
that because my school district paid for
services for my son that he did not
receive for the entire 20122 2023 school
year so they were paying for services
that he did not get so there are
services or funds that are expended that
questions thank you very much are there
go okay
Kristen
maner R
Ramy yeah it is a test you know I'll do
it Kristen mon sharani uh special
education advocate here in New Hampshire
okay uh I was not planning to testify on
this one but I just want to respond a
bit because I am concerned about the
interplay between the
finance um investigative committee
that's being set up with regard to
special education
dollars and this implication that um
some of these special education dollars
are going towards general education um I
think that it is important to delineate
special education dollars and to to
Really confine those to use in special
education and I do not think in any way
that it Prov vent some of the beneficial
situations that Miss Bon buo was just
discussing yes there are as I said
before there are sometimes very small
groups in which services are delivered
to a child receiving special education
paired with some other children in the
general education curriculum and those
benefit that special education child but
it would that that service would still
be in the service delivery grid of the
individualized education program for
that special education child so the
funding you know if a provider an
occupational therapist is working with
three children two of whom have IEPs one
of whom doesn't that funding is still a
I I don't think there's any question
about whether that is special education
funding because that person's time is
delineated in an IEP Service delivery
grid for that child so I I the other
point that we're talking about is this
multi-tiered system of support and that
I think is a concern that you know we
need to dive further into because it is
absolutely true that sometimes and this
came up a bit earlier we're seeing
referrals to special education
because multi-tiered systems of support
at at sort of a tier one level that that
you know the first interventions we
should be doing do need to be given more
broadly to you know 30% of the students
in the general education population and
those students shouldn't all be referred
to Special
Ed I personally have encountered a
number of districts where there seem to
be as we dug in to cases and disputes no
mechanism for children to have received
intervention services in the general
education
context therefore we're in disputes
about their eligibility for special
education because the student is
certainly falling further and further
behind and so again especially when
there's a committee that's being
designated for looking at special
education Finance dollars I think we
have to keep very separate these systems
so yes multi-tiered systems of support
on the first levels benefit everyone but
I wouldn't want to see those starting to
be lumped into special education dollars
because you're going to have the
concerns raised that we're spending so
much on special education when in fact
those are actually dollars being spent
in the general education classrooms that
should be there that might prevent more
special education referrals later on but
they're not the same pools of money and
they they really shouldn't be we we need
to distinguish those because we need to
start looking at what multi-tiered
systems of support for those general
education students who may not need to
get to special education referrals exist
or don't
exist and this is in mental health as
well because there's also a multitude
system of supports there and then where
it really should be special education
and and I think to be um clear when
we're looking at pools of money they
they ways to really delineate those and
they should be delineated and the fact
that some special education services
will be
delivered paired with some general
education students wouldn't make those
non-sp special education dollars but I
wouldn't want to see it going the other
way we we have to make sure that dollars
designated as special
education because there are a lot of
concerns about the level of spending in
special education we have to make sure
those dollars are not substituting in
even with the best of intentions from
your school administrators because they
might really have the best of intentions
look we need more supports provided in
some of our general Ed populations we
need more reading Specialists we need
math Specialists but those aren't
genuinely special education dollars and
I wouldn't want to see that get
comingled and
Confused thank you are there any
questions representative Pell thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question so as I read this obviously at
first glance it looks like this school
district has to be held accountable for
the money that they have spent but on
the other side of it on the revenue side
I see this as a way of making sure that
the School receives the revenue that
they need for the specialed students
would do you think that that could
possibly be a benefit of this
legislation or something similar yes I
do further questions from the committee
not seeing it thank you very much we're
going to close this
one okay I'm going to introduce this for
uh repres
Roy I'm just going to I'm just going to
uh introduce it and not
speak that was the one that de asked me
to introduce not on it what I know but
somebody else asked her to introduce it
and now she can't and she brought it to
me and ask
Med
okay 14 1444 43 yeah okay good it's not
ahead militia leus Hillsboro 38 I am
just introducing this bill
and not answering any questions but
there are people from uh the doe who can
answer questions who are here in the
room if you're introducing it you're and
you don't plan to answer any questions
you're not going to read the any
paperwork the sponsor made just
introduce the Bill thank you that's it
so the bill is introduced thank you very
much so 1443 has been introduced and we
now will take testimony and Steven
brck
uh thank you for the opportunity to
speak with you today I am the
administrator for the office of dispute
resolution of constituent complaints for
the Department of Education uh part of
my role includes administering the
alternative dispute resolution processes
for the Department of Education RSA 186
c23 pertains in general terms to
Alternative dispute
resolution these are various processes
in which an impartial thirdparty assists
parents and school districts to resolve
a ver uh a
conflict one of these processes is
neutral conference which is in RSA 186c
23-b that is the statute that is being
amended in House Bill
1443 I want to bring your attention to
lines 6 and seven on page one select a
neutral on a rotational basis this
requested change reflects the fact that
the department currently has four
individuals who conduct all of the
Department's administrative processes
and allows for scheduling flexibility to
ensure coverage for all
processes we also ask for a change to
RSA 186 c24 to enable media mediators to
be assigned on a rotational instead of
regional basis as well for the same
reasons this change codifies NH Ed's
current
practice I next bring your attention to
line 23 is there any questions um line
six any
concerns um just just go have you done
all your testimony no I'm no let's let's
hear all the whole testimony and then
we'll follow up with questions at the
end that's fine thank you thank thank
you uh here the requested changes is to
add in the phrase unless Changed by
agreement of the parties provides more
flexibility to the parties and want to
to eliminate the time
constraint lastly I draw your attention
to lines 26 uh through 30 page 1 and
lines 1-2 on page two this addition
provides clear guidance as to what the
role of the neutral is to be the reason
we are asking this to be in the law is
because the role of the neutral is
changing to provide the neutral with
more opportunity for interaction with
the parties currently neutral
conferences are more like a mini hearing
and as such may be part of the overall
reason why they have not been regularly
utilized the language was taken from
elements of the now discontinued third
party led by Mo moderator at one point
we had three different alternative
dispute resolution processes and we've
eliminated one the added language
provides for more proactive discussion
between the parties and the neutral
similar in some respects to mediation
but unlike mediation with the ultimate
aim of the neutral offering the parties
an opinion which can be adopted by the
parties a mediator cannot off offer an
opinion it's especially useful and was
something that had been requested by
stakeholders to have the neutral to be
able to offer an verbal opinion as to
whether the remedy remedy a party seeks
is allowed under the
law with such a verbal opinion it may
help to refocus the issue the changes to
allow for the neutral to provide
insights as to how a hearing officer May
view the particular matter can also help
to open dialogue between the parties
it's felt that if these changes are made
to the current law it will provide the
parties with a much more userfriendly
alternative to a due process hearing or
regular
mediation
and uh thank you if there are any
questions are there any questions yes
representative uh Pete thank you stepen
um um I'm just playing the role of a
potted represent so I
understand Stephen could you walk us
through the whole process um you know
it's been a long long time since I
worked at the department and and how
does a complaint come to you then what
happens next and and how do we get to
the dispute resolution so in terms of
neutral conference what happens is if
the parties uh decide that they don't
want to go through a due process hearing
or even if they do but they select to
use neutral conference then the school
district will submit the paperwork uh
request for neutral conference in this
instance a uh agreement to neutral
conference and also we require the
school districts could be considered ad
hoc I suppose uh commitment of resources
of the school district and the reason
why we do that is a protection for
parents because if something is agreed
to in a neutral conference I think I've
told you this years ago then um we don't
want the school district to you know
officials to go back to the school
district and say well the superintendent
doesn't agree to this well we have your
signature and it says you will agree to
whatever is agreed to when the parties
are in the room together and so that's
how it comes to us and what happens is
that uh if the parties have have
specific dates that they would like to
do a proceeding we try to utilize those
dates uh and rotationally with who is
available because we have a lot of
processes and then uh we schedule it and
the neutral uh will meet with the
parties uh and um currently they would
each side would get a half an hour they
have um four up to four pages of
documents that they can provide prior to
5 days I think it is prior to and then
at the um at the conclusion the neutral
can render a decision and the parties
can adopt it or decide not to so that's
the current and that's what we're trying
to change y thank you further questions
from the committe representative Damon
thank you Mr chair thank you for helping
us understand this could you tell us
what the qualifications of a neutral are
so all of our neutrals are currently
attorneys they're all admitted to the
bar in New Hampshire uh and they all
have education
background yes follow y they have
special education
background well uh two of the so the
answer is probably going to be yes I I
don't know that because I don't have it
in front of me I don't have their
resums but they've been doing um one
current one James Baron had been a
parent attorney and represented parent
uh parents in special education cases in
Massachusetts as well as New Hampshire
uh Scott Johnson is also um well
acquainted with special ed law he's been
an attorney for years represented
parents uh and um let's see they're
going to be upset if I remember that uh
Brianna kley had been a parent attorney
who would also represented uh parents
and Special Education cases on the SE
Coast Area previously and Peter Foley
had been a former attorney uh Assistant
Attorney General and had been he doesn't
do special education due process
hearings very much
but he does special ed and does
mediations uh and also vocation
Rehabilitation so that's the background
so I guess the answer to your question
is
yes thank you further question
representative Miler thank you Mr chair
and thank you for being here I'm a bit
confused on the term option versus
opinion can you can you I I one hand I
hear I thought I I thought I heard you
say that they provide options another
time I heard you say they give opinions
so could you please clarify that for me
absolutely happy to do so so an option
is what we're looking for in the change
to the to the neutral conference because
in this instance they would be acting as
we we had a we had a a third procedure
called third party discussion led by
moderator and they would at the
conclusion provide options so you not
just a opinion
but different options that you might
want to think about in order to resolve
the dispute and um so that's the
difference one would be an opinion which
is what the current neutral conf uh
neutral conference would be and the
parties could
adapt um the or excuse me adopt the
opinion and then it becomes binding on
the
parties uh or the in this instance the
neutral could provide them with options
in what we're
asking so different options that they
could think about and if they decide
upon one then that can become an
agreement between the parties and
reduced to written form so followup
please yes so you're you're basically
trying to broaden correct the role of
the individual to provide those those
options correct it it goes back to so we
were uh part of the part of the um audit
and and we had had the third opportunity
which was third party uh discussion led
by moderator and we had utilized U
advice from the Attorney General's
office but the Auditors have determined
that that's ad hoc and we can't do that
unless we go through um this process you
know to request um a law change and so
we we realized that the neutral
conferences weren't be they were being
underutilized through the years and the
number numers um are like for example
1995 when the law was promulgated
originally you had four requests and one
agreement and 1996 we had one request
and which was withdrawn so there was no
agreement and to 1997 we had five
requests and all were withdrawn so
unfortunately neutral conferences
weren't being utilized and more current
uh we had um only seven neutral
conferences with one agreement in 2018
and one in 2021 so the thought is is
that if we utilize the neutral
conference that we have but change it a
bit it can be more utilized because
people were using the moderator session
more um
and I don't want to you know confuse and
overstate everything but it was at there
was a meeting uh with attorneys and
Advocates back in
1993 and they suggested that the
department should have an alternative
process where somebody could go and say
what do you think of this case and so
that's how moderator sessions had come
about so we put
our um our heads together and did a teay
and came up with well we don't why don't
we just change the neutral conference
and then we'll have one less process but
this will opport give an opportunity for
parties to be able to see how it might
go without spending all the time and
effort on a due process hearing
my long-winded explanation
representative
Corell thank you and thank you for
taking my question how was this offered
to the two parties is it like if it if
if it people aren't agreeing and you
think it's going to go to Due Process
does somebody say you know this is an
option want to try this
or um it's on the it's
well it's on the website but also when
parties request a due process hearing we
do a uh a presumptive mediation any way
that they can opt out of and if they
decide to change that to a neutral
conference or third party that
information is
available um and it so that's how the
options come about or if they call and
ask what do you have available we
provide that to them as
well further questions from the
committee thank you very much don't any
hands thank you uh i' like to invite uh
uh chairman ladin education committee
I'm here today to oppose this bill um on
its face I don't have any issue with
neutral conference however neutral
conference is not an access access
format to normal parents who don't have
a legal background I don't know if
anybody here has ever gone through
neutral conference but you actually lay
out a legal case and the person gives
you a legal opinion on what they think
would happen with your case if you
actually went through with it in full
court um because of that I don't feel
that people who don't speak English I
don't feel that parents who cannot
afford an attorney and I don't feel that
um prosay parents can adequately
represent themselves and that's why I
oppose it I actually think that neutral
conf conf should be struck from the
options and we should reduce the number
of options that are available most
parents don't know what neutral
conference is and um I work on a
committee that deals with dispute
resolution and um parent information
center had recommended to strike it and
at first I had thought people should
have as many options as possible but in
consideration of it I actually do agree
that it should be stricken and there
should be fewer options and things that
are more accessible to parents and
ordinary people who have to represent
themselves prosay because again it costs
$20,000 just for a file review and
that's the price of a small car so with
that being said I do oppose this bill
and I'm happy to take any
questions 20,000 a money for a very very
small car would that's true but that
means a lot to me $20,000 for me to Fork
out is quite a bit of money sir okay are
questions I don't see any hands thank
try I'm not going to go with that
Kristen
D Kristen
manani okay Office of the special
education Advocate and it is much easier
if you're looking at it man sharani is
sort of fonetic um I am opposed to this
as well and I it will Echo a bit of what
Miss Ryan just said but I want to get
into a bit more Det in terms of what I
am experiencing that our families
experience and trying to settle disputes
I first and foremost this idea that more
choice is always better you know there's
some psychology around this um and I
think it definitely plays in in the
special education dispute resolution it
is not always better because parents are
confused by the range of paths and
options and choices that they have in
front of them and no matter what they
they choose they spend a lot of time and
energy and sometimes money on whatever
path they've chosen to go down for
dispute
resolution when it doesn't yield a
result that they feel is fair you know
you can have results that parents
weren't looking for but that they at
least feel like they have some
transparency into the process and I
actually have to commend um Mr Burwick
and I I I think the due process dispute
resolution
here um it is very difficult for parents
to navigate on their own but I think
there is transparency to it and I think
that when parents go through it they
really can point to okay what caused my
case to go for me or against me and I
heard everyone's testimony Etc um so to
come back to the neutral conference and
to set the stage a bit here the neutral
conference is part of an alternative
dispute resolution set of options
there's also a dispute resolution set of
options where due process lives and
where filing a state complaint live and
so a parent has to actually sort that
out as well should I be filing a state
complaint should I be filing a request
for a due process hearing and then there
are many steps after you file the
request for the due process hearing most
of which parents do not understand as
they go into
them before you even get to Alternative
dispute resolution which is your neutral
conferences and your mediations
mediation is also part of the dispute
resolution due process you've gone
through numerous IEP team meetings you
might have have had IEP facilitation
that you've heard of here so you feel as
a parent you're you you already feel
like you've tried and tried and tried
sometimes for years to settle these
disputes before you get to either
dispute resolution or alternative
dispute resolution so then having
numerous options in each of those I
actually think takes away from the
process I think it it has led to a lot
more frustration from parents because
they feel like I've filed complaints
everywhere I could find to file them and
I've spent tons of money sometimes if I
do have representation or I've spent
years of my child's educational life
trying to solve
disputes I think you know what I'm
hoping that my agency will be able to
work with the oon is is some
simplification of some of this and some
really um in-depth discussions
about how do we make it so that parents
are not sort of circling the system in
all these different dispute Mech
resolution mechanisms for years so
neutral conference
specifically um I I probably am much
more with Miss Ryan but I'm not sure how
useful that mechanism is and I have
concerns about it from the perspective
of representing parents
so I found our mediation process to be
reasonably um useful and many of the
things that are delineated here as
options we want to have in the neutral
conference I think are already happening
potentially in mediation now parents can
request mediation or districts can
request mediation as an alternative
dispute resolution or they can opt into
it as one step along the way to their
due process hearing if they've requested
the due process dispute
resolution in
mediation it is more informal and it's
more of a comfortable setting for
parents I'm not saying parents don't
benefit from having an adviser with them
they do in mediation but in mediation
that those same hearing officers who
would be the hearing officers in neutral
conference are breaking breaking out
into sessions it's a much more
conversational piece they're talking to
each side independently they are
answering questions I found the
mediators more than willing to answer
questions about whether they think that
the parents claim and the type of relief
the parent might be seeking in due
process is viable with they as a hearing
officer if the
facts lined up orward that type of
relief um you know they when I've
participated with parents in mediations
the hearing officers they the mediators
um are pretty open they're pretty they
they discuss they go back and forth
between the sides often extensively and
I think it is a much less intimidating
process for parents I also think it
doesn't require that they be prepared to
lay out the of legal case with all of
their documents you know in order the
exhibits they're going to refer to um
the
writeups um extensively that they would
put in for a neutral conference it
doesn't require that they be prepared
for that in the same way that a neutral
conference
does whether or not even if you had a
school district on one side and the
family on the other in a neutral
conference and if neither party was
represented in that conference by
Advocates or attorneys
your District
Representatives have they they are
experts in the special education field
they have without a doubt discussed that
specific
situation over months or or longer with
the district
attorneys so they're set up to
understand what the legal issues they're
presenting are going into that neutral
conference the families on the other
hand are just talking about their
frustrations if they have no legal
counsel they really may not know how to
ground their argument in something that
um can be offered legally and I know
that one of the things we've said is
okay the hearing officers will give you
some options they'll try to maybe help
you think that way I think that happens
much more in
mediation I think the neutral conference
format with the formality of it um puts
a hand on the district side of the scale
because they're going to be more
prepared for that formal presentation
and the parent walks out of that having
spent again tons of time put a lot of
hopes into this with a an
opinion that they either do or don't
have a legal case um that I think really
influences
their propensity to settle or to keep
pursuing something that is actually to
their satisfaction um I again here I
just I don't think it's not it's not
a forum for dispute resolution that I
would recommend to unrepresented parents
I'd rather see them not be so reticent
or hesitant to go down the due process
path um and what I hope we can do is
expand the core of Advocates Etc you
know people who can uh represent
McDonald thank you Mr chair and thank
you so much for being here and for
testifying a number of bills today I
understand that you do not favor the
concept of a neutral conference and this
bill is not instituting that into law
it's already in statute it just has some
changes to how the neutral conference
would go about specifically line six
where it would say selecting a neutral
on a rotational basis do you believe
that would improve the neutral cont
conference and address some of the
concerns that you mentioned or would
this make the process even more
confusing or difficult for parents so I
don't think those lines on how we select
the neutrals have an impact one way or
another from the from the the fairness
to either side or whether I would
recommend the process I think you know I
would favor giving doe that flexibility
um as they said they have a limited
number of uh people who serve in these
roles um so I don't have any concern
with that I do have some concerns with
kind of expanding the options for those
officers expanding the idea of the
neutral conference theoretically with
the idea to make it more accessible
because I I don't think that's really
what will happen I don't think it will
be beneficial to parents
okay thank you further questions
representative Miler thank you Mr chair
and thank you for being here uh I need
help I mean a lot of people think I need
help but on this particular thing I do
because I'm confused at options here so
if you help me walk through this all
right so we've we've come up with an as
I understand it we come up with an
IEP and as a parent I have some concerns
about my issues for my child are not
being met by that IEP and I want to
challenge that process so if you could
be if you could very
rudiment say you've got this option to
pursue you've got this option to pursue
and help clarify in my mind exactly what
that uh what that appeal process the
various phases of the appeal process
process that would be very helpful for
me if you could do that sure I'm going
to try to do this as succinctly as
possible your question gets at the heart
of the issue here of
why there is so much confusion to
dispute resolution so um when families
come to our office and say by the way
we've crossed a hurdle already by saying
the child has an IEP because it means
we've gone through a whole referral
process and evaluations and had them
designated and there are some parents
who are are fighting way back at that
step um that they you know that the
school is telling them you don't need
services and the parents say yes we do
but let's say we've gotten through that
we have the IEP um so this goes you know
before I launch into this tangent I like
to tell people where it's going so I'm
going to tell you the kinds of questions
I would ask and then I'm going to say
remember I said that I think it's very
hard as a parent to present your legal
case well if you haven't had any
preparation and the districts know
exactly where to present the legal
issues in their case because they're
experts in this so I often say to
families who call okay I'm going to ask
a few
questions what specifically is the
designation of disability in your
child's
IEP most of my families even though
they're in dispute resolution can't
actually answer that question until we
look at the IEP that's because there
were about 13 categories one of them is
something as big as other health
impairment which could accom you know
cover a whole bunch of things all of
these point to where your services are
you know your your designation of
disability tends to drive your areas of
need your service providers and your
related service providers
Etc so we we get to that question I ask
them you know who are the providers in
in your what does Your Service delivery
grid look like what kinds of services is
your child having and how many times a
week and from
whom also tough for parents to look at
we usually have to go to the IEP look at
the service delivery grid actually do
track it through what specifically are
the goals in your child's
IEP in the areas of need that that you
don't think are adequate right or that
Services aren't
meeting often these IEPs are 30 page
very legal documents those goals you
have to really go through and find and
we have to look it is it that the goals
are written wrong they're not specific
enough they don't give you measurable
progress and then the fourth question is
really just where's your child placed is
your child full inclusion do they have a
resource room placement do they have a
special education separate special
education room placement between those
three often parents don't know the
answer they do know the answer if
they're in a separate special education
school or or you know more restrictive
so there are so many different places
that your dispute
really properly could be lodged and what
parents know to say is my child's just
not making progress or school's going
really wrong for them and to actually
make the case for a lot of these
resolutions if they're that unspecific
then you're going to an IEP team meeting
as your first step and saying that I
don't feel like my child's making
progress these are the things that feel
like they're going wrong with
school so then it's incumbent on the
district team to sort of say to the
parent okay here are ways we can solve
that you know we can look at a referrals
we can look at your
goals um we think there is progress
under your goals Etc this can be long
processes it's can be months of time
that goes by with this and you might
disagree you have the IEP team
facilitations so that's step number two
right not everyone takes advantage of
that um our office we would go and and
be helping parents in those I AP team
meetings first we've usually been in
several I AP team meetings before we get
to any kind of dispute
resolution at that point parents have an
option
does the type of thing you're
complaining about fall better under a
state complaint which goes to the doe
there's not a ton of transparency it
would be articulated as something that
the district is is not complying with
the law there's an
investigation parents do not see all of
that
investigation they will see a decision
from the commissioner of
Education as a result of that
investigation usually a couple Pages
instructing something where ing the
District of having done something wrong
there so parents could choose
that or they could choose one of these
alternative dispute resolution they
could choose to have a neutral
conference or a
mediation or they could choose to file
for a due process hearing if they choose
one and that's the one they have to take
they can't come back and and double
jeopardy so so to speak is that correct
no not necessarily I would say not
simultaneous ly for the most part
without getting two in the weeds and I'd
invite um Miss Fenton or Mr bck to
correct me here afterwards if they'd
like but um for the most part you're
you're trying to go down One path at a
time not all of the paths at a time but
again we're taking time from a child's
education and we're taking a parent's
resources and energy so this can be
yearslong processes depending on how you
pick to do this um which is why I'd like
to see it streamlined um so so you could
have picked neutral conference you could
have picked mediation I think you
wouldn't pick the two at the same time
right those are
alternatives or you could have picked
due process and ended up with a
resolution session with the district
first and then a mediation which
involves a third party that resolution
session with the district does not um
and then and then SE several other steps
um I I
think you can hear from just how come
complex it is to tryy to describe it
because within every one of those steps
there's a lot of work so how hard it is
for parents is get on to another
question representa K Kaden thank you Mr
chair and thank you so I want to kind of
organize this in my mind and want either
verification from you or not the way I'm
interpreting it there are two ways of
alternative disputes informal informal
this morning we talked about IEP
facilitation in my mind
that would be an informal process to get
another professional to advise on a
consensus on an IEP goal or a placement
or something to that effect whereas the
neutral conference Falls more in the
formal realm which might be a process
just prior to doe to due
process on the legal side is does that
sort of pocket it or not all right I'm
going to try it this way in two or three
sentences can you try to do that now
quickly because we're so up here you
have IEP team meetings and IEP
facilitation levels one and
1A then you could go to either
alternative dispute resolution which is
either mediation or a neutral conference
okay or you could go to formal dispute
resolution a state complaint or due
process okay under those there are many
other options all right thank you thank
you are there further questions from the
committee representative
Damon could you please send us a
document of what you just diagrammed and
I am serious sure no right I I I will
coordinate with the OE to make sure we
all agree on that flowchart are there
further further questions from the
committee represent cordelli thank you
from the
um um from the neutral
conference um if you do not select an
option um and maybe they say that um
there might be a legal
case uh then do you switch
tracks um and jump over to dispute
resolution you could okay simple answer
okay thank you very much are there
further questions from the
much those are different
we are now finished uh the hearing on on
this bill and we'll prepare to go
forward with the hearing on
1382 which is uh relative to special
just
navigate
uh we'll open the hearing on House Bill
1382 relative to special education
support for military connected students
and I recognize uh chairman lad to
introduce the Bill thank you very much
uh representative cordelli and members
of the education committee I met with
representative Roy he's unable to be
here uh I saw him at lunchtime he was
looking for somebody had military
experience he hit me up and so I'm
introducing 1382 I'm not going to
discuss it as we did for the other bill
I'll come back to the chair and we will
uh continue with the bill with the next
people on Deck thank
Perry would
mindette
first yeah do we have okay I'm sorry see
your
yeah Melissa welcome thank you
sir Mr lad and honorable members of the
committee the Department of Defense is
grateful for the opportunity to support
the policies reflected in House Bill
1382 and hopes New Hampshire will
Implement these improvements to further
support military children in the granite
state my name is Melissa wette and I'm
the New England region liaison at the
Department of Defense State liaison
Office operating under the direction of
the under secretary of defense for
personnel and Readiness we represent the
department and establish relationships
with State leaders across the country to
enhance state laws and regulations on
policy problems of national significance
these are identified by the office of
the Secretary of Defense the military
departments and the National Guard
Bureau as areas where states can play a
crucial role in our nation's support for
military
families through the implementation of
these policy changes New Hampshire can
ensure service members are ready to
support the military Mission because the
state is supporting their children
creating an environment for military
families that enhances recruiting
resilience Readiness and retention
military children are largely adaptable
and demonstrate both flexibility and
resilience during permanent change of
station transitions however for children
with disabilities and transitions can be
difficult because they often have
Coordinated Care teams with their
therapists Specialists and Educators
that need to be reestablished by their
family with every move military children
will change schools an average of six to
n times between kindergarten and 12th
grade for military families of children
with disabilities this cycle can be
especially overwhelming as the burden to
ensure continuity of care tends to fall
in the family at a time when those
service members may be dealing with a
variety of other military connected
stressors idea sets the minimum special
education requirements that all states
must follow to provide a free and
appropriate education while allowing
States flexibility to determine other
specifics Section 504 of The
Rehabilitation Act of
1973 protects qualified individuals from
discrimination based on their disability
including students in public education
who must have reasonable accommodations
in place to support that fate delays and
implementation of the support to
military children can create a loss of
educational opportunity and stand
counter to fape as they can contribute
to learning gaps these losses can be
magnified with each military move a
study conducted in 2020 found that 51%
of active duty families with a child and
special education had trouble
transferring their child's IEP to their
new school another study conducted in
2021 found that 31% of military families
indicated that their children with
disabilities went without services for
more than 60 days following their
military move and 42% reported that
their IEP was not implemented once they
arrived at their new Duty station states
can ameliorate these issues in the
education Arena by ensuring policies are
in place to support military children
section one of this legislation before
you amends chapter Services when the
military connected student arrives at
their new school district section two
clarifies in statute that evaluations
must be conducted expeditiously no more
than 30 days after the military
connected students transfer from another
state even if it occurs during summer
recess or during an intermediate period
this is consistent with a November 2022
letter issued to All State directors of
special education by the US Department
of Education strongly encouraging school
districts to expedite their valuations
of Highly mobile children which includes
military connected children section
three proposes the reimbursement of
expert witness fees and due process
cases in which hearing officers find in
favor of the parents of a military
connected child reducing burdens during
special education proceedings is a top
priority for military families in
situations where parents in school
systems can't come to an agreement on
the provision of special education
services federal law through idea
provides for procedural safeguards to
help both parties work through that
disagreement this includes a voluntary
mediation process filing a state
complaint and due process which
typically involves hiring an attorney
and potentially paying significant fees
to expert
Witnesses procedural safeguards are
those Rights created by the idea to
assist parents and school systems
working through disagreements and to
ensure the playing field is level
between both parties there have been
anecdotal reports of school systems
delaying actions for the children of
military parents knowing they are less
likely to have the time or money
necessary to utilize these
safeguards and even in cases where
military parents are successful in due
process hearings relocation of the
family due to military orders can make
executing the hearing officers orders
very difficult to level the playing
field for military children and to uh uh
and to encourage school districts to
work with parents to come to a consensus
prior to Due Process states can take
action to enhance these procedural
safeguards this includes the
reimbursement of expert witness fees
should the hearing officer find in favor
of the parent in conclusion the policies
incorporated into this bill offer a
framework to serve military families
impa impacted by disabilities and
enhance the resiliency and Readiness of
our service members and their families
we thank the committee for considering
this important legislation and are
especially grateful for the tremendous
efforts New Hampshire has historically
made in supporting our service members
and their families we also thank the
bill sponsor representative Terry Roy
for his continued advocacy and support
and for your service to our country uh
as well Mr chair thank you thank you
very much uh I'll start out with a
question here um I can recall when we
met and put the interstate compact in
place in our statutory language and and
I thought we had addressed some of these
concerns and issues that you bring up
where there there section when our
interstate compact here military compact
with that address special education
dispute resolution attendance placement
Etc there's also a portion I believe as
I'm reading it here um where it's
underneath uh oversight enforcement and
dispute resolution it says that uh that
the interstate commission can take an
issue to The District Court the district
Federal District Court either one in
Washington DC or one other and the
relief s may include both injunctive
relief and damages in the event judicial
enforcement is necessary the prevailing
party shall be awarded all costs of such
litigation including reasonable attorney
fees so does that cover what we're
trying to do in this bill I believe it
would Mr chair however this policy um if
implemented would allow the parents to
not have to go through that particular
process with the district court and
would they would work directly with the
school district in order to recoup those
costs okay I followed up then we also
have a portion within the military
compact where the IEP that comes in from
the sending District you might be
somewhere over in the UK or wherever you
may be or another state even um that the
IEP must be filed the local district has
the option to give another placement
test and to subsequently develop an IEP
that might be more current or
appropriate for the setting their end so
how with that being said we're still
having to operate as we would do uh in
accordance with this compact we'd have
to immediately jump onto the whole
process I'm I'm you know I I absolutely
support this did back when we put it in
the law but I'm wondering are is this
becoming duplicative of what we have in
law receiving states do have to
initially provide those comparable
services but it doesn't necessarily no
there's no language that says
immediately provide comparable services
so our our military connected families
are still having a problem receiving
those services in a in a timely
manner um so that's where this 30-day um
policy proposal comes in
and as part of the legislation it is the
it's the due diligence of the parents to
provide the current IEP for that student
from the sending school before they
transfer to the new school so that the
receiving school will have that document
upon arrival or before
arrival and well I I don't want to
become debating this thing but because I
support everything you're saying but I
feel it does say that in 110 n d colon 6
placement and attendance and it's
specifically special education it talks
the IEPs 504 plans uh the whole nine
yards and it says that um the receiving
State shall initially provide comparable
services and then have the option to
even expand if they so
desire and that to me means when the
student walks in the in the door um you
have a responsibility then to take
action with that current IE panel that
they're probably hand carrying with them
UND understood sir um but it's it is
still the experience of our our families
that those services are not being
provided so setting that 30-day timeline
would help
facilitate U those IEPs the creation of
those I thank you are there questions
from the committee representative
pel I just want to ask for the record
you're talking about students who
are um experiencing change of Duty
station pretty frequently every 2 3
years sometimes more often so the
continuity of their educational care if
you will is really of the utmost
importance in these situations is that
correct that's correct on average um PCS
those permanent change of station moves
occur every two to three years but there
are some instances where a military uh
service members are relocating every 9
to 12 months depending on their military
occupational specialty and if they do
have a child with um a learning
disability um that becomes problematic
for the child uh in their continuity in
education further questions represent
Miler thank you Mr chair and thank you
for being here uh I am familiar with the
dod schools and I've been had the
pleasure of being with teachers in
Germany
England uh Korea and Japan and uh they
provide one heck of an education for
those kids and I comp compliment them
for the work they do for the one of the
things they've always have said that
it's great teaching there because they
have no discipline
problems because of the discipline
problem nobody wants to go to the
Commanding General there and have their
child there so it's nice but anyway on
this point so this is an interesting
issue so if if for example if I'm if I
live in uh Portsmith for example and I'm
deployed to vpot in Germany and I have a
child
who uh my residence is in uh pouth but
I'm deployed for a period of time let's
say a couple years to vpot in Germany
and I have a special ed
child is the Portsmouth School District
then
responsible for the special ed services
in that facility in
vpot the parent of the student would be
responsible for providing that IEP or
that paperwork work to the doia school
in Germany okay so then if I have a
dispute with uh whatever the services
might be and it's the dispute obviously
is going to be with the Portsmouth
School District I'm now looking at the
specific language of the of the bill
here where it says witness fees encourag
by the
parents so and if if if I Prevail in my
concern about that does that mean that
the school district would pay for
whatever witnesses that I bring to that
particular uh that particular hearing if
it was the DOA school um that you were
going through the due process hearings
with it would be the DOA school that
would pay for those witness fees if it
was the Portsmith school um that you
went through that due process hearing
with and they found in favor of you um
they would pay for the witness fees
according to this policy okay thank you
you're welcome further further questions
from the
committee not see thank you very much
thank you Mr uh Warren is it good time
you he's testified here
before so Mr chair uh members of the
committee for the record my name is
Warren Perry I'm the deputy agitant
general for New Hampshire's Department
of military Affairs and veterans
Services uh that includes the National
Guard of New Hampshire the division of
veteran services the division of
community- based military programs and
the Veteran Cemetery uh we we are
charged to take care of the veteran
population in the state and all of the
service members uh veterans and their
families in the state so this kind of
falls into our purview of something that
we wanted to to uh to support the
department supports the bill as written
without having looked at the compact to
see if it was duplicative so I'll just
you helped us do that I I well I didn't
but Carol protzman did Carol protzman
did yes absolutely and she was wonderful
when that got done at the time I was
still on active duty I wasn't working
for the state at that time I was the
Inspector General for the state here at
that time but uh so what I would say is
that the timing of this is really kind
of the key uh the key piece right so to
make sure that that we don't have a lag
in Services uh for military children
that are moving I know that I don't have
children that have IEPs or had special
education needs but you know more than
once in my 28 year military career my
children were in at least three
classrooms in one year so the continuity
of that care is important and the timing
by which that's delivered the continuity
of that care is really important so if
we're not getting timely resources to
the to the children and their families
as we go forward to me that's really the
uh the issue that's that's critical here
so if if this bill is duplicative I
would just ask you know that the
committee consider looking going back
and doing a deeper dive into the into
the compact which I will when I leave
the committee today to make sure that
those time Horizons are there so that
we're not losing getting to 60 days
without Services 60 days without a good
IEP going you know we're getting
somebody into the school system getting
them access to the to the resources that
they need to have good continuity of
Education educational resources that
they go so subject to any questions you
might have that's the end of my St thank
you are there any questions from the
committee yes rep Tanner thank you and
thank you for your service um is this uh
just active duty or is it also veterans
so this this bill way it's written
applies to Children of active duty
service members so in the state of New
Hampshire we think that population is
somewhere between 11 and 1200 active
duty service members and of that we
believe there are about 800 children
some of which will be school age
children it's not all of them
necessarily will be school age children
if that helps further question yes
representative Cornel thank you and
thank you for your service and taking my
question have has this been a problem in
New Hampshire or or is this legislation
to just make sure that it's prepared I
can't I can't speak to that I don't I
don't really get into the education
pieces of things I would tell you that
we would generally probably not hear in
my department that it was a problem
unless it was a real chronic problem
Like Somebody went to the Department of
Education and they didn't get the
satisfaction that they were looking for
then they'd start looking for somebody
else to call we don't hear that kind of
noise if I can use that term in our
department but I you know it I would say
that just because we're not hearing it
doesn't mean it's not happening and just
because we're not hearing it doesn't
mean that it is happening so I think the
Department of Education would have a
better feel for that I will tell you
from my experience most of the school
districts in New Hampshire would not
have the same sensitivity to this issue
because they there's not a big military
population in any one school district in
New Hampshire so like if you were
outside of Fort cavaso which used to be
Fort Hood uh you know every kid that
comes in is a military child and they
would have that experience here I think
would I think the school districts would
be more sensitive there's less turnover
less churn you know on a military
installation oneir of the installation
turns over every year onethird so I
don't think it's a huge problem but it
certainly would be good to make sure
that if there was people would have a
standard that they could go to a time
standard that they could go to whether
that's in the compact or this
legislation I don't I think that answers
your question are there any further
questions this whole thing just amazes
me you know I live right outside
Elmendorf and Richard up in Anchorage
and there we had a higher percentage of
turnover which were military
yes I ap's transferred back and forth
just you know without a question and if
there is a problem here because I was
under under the understanding that this
was occurring that we were do due to
that compact yeah kids should not have
to wait they're they're the IEP
transfers with them and they're good to
go with that IEP yes there should not be
any delay at all that's wonderful and
encouraging to hear and and I and I know
you representative you have you know
your finger on this more than we do at
the department I I'm just you know I'm
you know stating our our support for the
the outcome that this bill is trying to
do and if it's being met in the compact
we'll be happy with that if it's not
being C if it's not being met in the in
the compact we should probably go look
and see that it is thank you very much
Grady
good afternoon Mr chairman ladies and
gentlemen of the committee I'll be I'll
be fairly brief with my remarks today
for the record my name is Kevin Grady I
am a 25y year veteran of our air force
and I'm a 25 year resident of the town
of hooks at New Hampshire today I'm here
representing the state veterans advisory
committee which are we are 20 veteran
service organizations in the state their
names would be familiar to you things
like the VFW the American Legion
representatives from all of the services
Association if you will and we're
chartered by state RSA 115 colon a-8 if
you want to look it up to speak for the
veteran community in New Hampshire and
one of the things that we do we have a
legislative committee which I chair and
we look at the bills that are coming
before the legislature each year and
this year there are 20 of them and we
separate out the ones that have the
military impact and then we come and
tell you what our opinion is uh like uh
Deputy adant General Perry we do support
the conception this this idea of making
sure that this is good again the
specific language if it's better done in
the compact or maybe just a little tweak
to the compact is necessary that's great
um we think it's very important for that
continuity of instru of of of
instruction for a student particularly
with an IEP now in my post a force life
I did spend uh 11 years as a school
teacher in uh in Hudson New Hampshire I
represented leas I started the Air Force
Junior r2c program at alurn back in the
day back in ' 04 and I've attended my
share of IEP meetings and I I've had
probably 10 to 15% of my students had
IEPs and I understand the critical
importance of all of this as I reflected
on my own military career I moved nine
times three of those were in the summer
the other six times were off cycle
November December January February so
times when it would have been difficult
if ID had a child with an IEP which
fortunately I did not that that could
have been a a a significant issue we
want for the students to be able to get
in quickly get their IEP from their
previous uh School implemented if if our
folks can do a better job with it that's
a wonderful thing we really like that
idea maybe maybe we have access to
Services here in New Hampshire that they
didn't at their last Duty station for
whatever reason so we love that idea and
I think if we do the first part of this
thing right then the second part with
the with the uh you know getting fees if
this has to go to court that stuff's
never going to be a factor it's just
going to be done correctly the first
time the last thing and we've done a
great job of this in our state I believe
of uh of making people feel welcome you
know we're we're NE we're trying to
recruit the next group of people that
are going to come and make their life in
New Hampshire when they get out of the
military and be part of our community
and raise their families here so uh I we
F fully support this bill and subject to
any questions that you have uh get off
the stage thank you very much any
questions from the
committee thank you very much than you
Mr
last good afternoon and thank you for
the opportunity to testify um this
afternoon my name is Jane Bon bullu I'm
the executive director for the New
Hampshire Association of special ed
administrators and I am here
representing um over 270 leaders in the
field of special
education um I am here representing our
members we're not taking a stance on the
bill either Pro or con but just wanted
to bring um some thoughts to your
attention for consideration first of all
um our Association members wanted me to
share that we recognize and agree that
there is such an importance in
supporting our military families
especially those that have students with
IEPs um we find that you know when
military families come in we need to
give them the extra support um and
transitions are hard for kids especially
kids with um individual um education
plans when we looked at the bill um
there were a few things that we um
thought about and the first one is
around the enrollment of students um
with IEPs when they come in to our
schools and currently there are very
specific guidelines that we have to
adhere to in the field of special
education when a child enrolls we have
30 days to meet convene with the team
which includes the family review the IEP
and updated and make sure that the
student um IEP is implemented um in in
previous testimony we talked about the
interstate uh compact um and I'm a part
of that we meet regular ly and it
includes um folks uh superintendents um
Kathleen Murphy it was appointed as the
um Point person for that group we have
um folks from the Portsmith Naval
Shipyard uh we have Educators we have
parents um and and this issue hasn't
really come up um and it was my
understanding that these kinds of things
were um covered under the compact so
kind of took us by surprise and if there
are things that aren't working um our
association would love to know about it
so that we can begin to work with our
members and school districts um to begin
um addressing any challenges that we're
not aware of um the other thing that we
would mention that um in this bill in
terms of the language um throughout the
bill it refers to an IEP evaluation that
when a child moved in um the school
district would be required to do an IEP
evaluation and we question that language
um the term
evaluation typically lends itself to um
the assessment of a student and specific
tests that you have to give uh to
students to become identified um as a
student with a disability um or it means
an evaluation to assess a student so
typically when an IEP comes in it's not
evaluated it's reviewed by the team uh
to determine the appropriateness and how
we're going to go about um implementing
the services so that was also brought to
our attention um other than that like I
said we we also question the fiscal note
um in terms of um you know paying the
fees and wondered where that money was
going to to come from um and so those
were the comments that um our
association uh asked me to bring forward
we appreciate the opportunity to testify
and we' be happy to take any questions
thank you very much are there any
questions yes representative cordelli um
yes regarding height thank thanks for
sticking around um in regard to comments
about an
evaluation um wouldn't you think though
that um uh military family transferring
from overseas someplace uh for instance
um it might be
necessary for an evaluation regarding
the IEP that they're bringing with them
um after all they're coming you know
from a military base granted from in a
foreign country but still in a foreign
country not knowing um you know
everything that's available to them
there um wouldn't you think that an
evaluation would be um the best course
of
action yeah I mean I think we're just
questioning the the language we're
required by law to do a 30-day review of
an IEP when the student moves in I mean
they have the the school district you
know is held to that timeline um it just
was questionable we wouldn't want to put
a student through another set of
evaluations if they didn't need it so
that the language was just a bit
confusing and probably should align with
current special education
rules thank you further question
represent so then should that be uh
review as opposed to evaluation or what
are you suggesting I think we would
suggest that we you know if the bill
were to move forward that align with the
current
um expectations within the special
education rules and currently um when a
child is enrolled doesn't matter if it's
a military family or kid from another
District um I the district is required
to convene the IEP team and review that
IEP within 30 days so there is specific
language already okay and would you get
that to us what that language is
specifically thank you very much thank
you any further questions
from thank you very much you're welcome
welcome I want to just ask everybody in
the committee to read the compact in
Article 5 because it talks about
evaluations also it says this does not
preclude the school in the receiving
state from performing subsequent
evaluation to ensure appropriate
placement of the
student now I I I you know I'm all for
if it's not being done we got to do
something
but this is done this language right
here replicated in all 50
states so we're messing with a compact
and I'm concern and there there this
is this is a thorough compact it's a
whole chapter of law so please read it
over NE next um person and last person
Department um that particular article on
page
65 thank you representative vad my name
is Rebeca fet I'm from the Department of
Education I'm the director of special
education um I I want we're not
supporting or not supporting this we
understand that military families have
unique situations and we hope that
anyone would um provide the services
they need my um concern is just a
technical one which was brought up by
Jane berson with the evaluation piece um
it's the language is unclear whether
we're saying that an evaluation needs to
be done within 30 days or if we just
need to review the IEP within 30 days so
if it's the IEP that make that's as she
said that's already in law if it's the
evaluation and then subsequently an IEP
we're taking a 120-day process and doing
it within 30 days so that would be my
concern is if we have to and then if we
have to evaluate every single child that
comes in that's going to delay their
services so I guess there needs to be a
little Clarity for me to understand if
I'm supporting districts and saying you
do need to evaluate a child every time
they come in from a military base or if
I'm saying you need to review their IEP
and meet as soon as possible once they
come from from a military
base thank you very much and to respond
to that when we did this the intent was
the IEP comes in is good and if the
district discerns that there need to do
something follow the procedure that's
outlined in in idea and the laws and
statutes you follow right so I think we
have this thing covered I hope we have
it covered because we had a long
discussion on this article 5 when we
yep so thank you Jessica vif
representing myself but also
superintendent
SCH um I would just like to offer some
consideration of language in here to
reiterate what was previously brought up
by a couple of people um it's really in
the semantics of the language in here
that I'm I'm concerned about and curious
it might be adjusted a little bit um
was the
evaluation regarding the IEP shall be
conducted 30 days so evaluation and I
are two separate things within the
specialized process and those two terms
being put together are a confusing
sentiment in so evaluation cannot be
completed within 30 days that's a 90 up
to 90day process um that the school
district goes through with a student um
schools are obligated when a student
comes in with an IEP as soon as they
learn that a child has an IEP they're
obligated Implement that IEP immediately
to their best ability as it currently
stands then they have 30 days to review
that IEP see what is the best interest
of the child get feedback from the
parent and then have that meeting to
amend that IEP to accept it in um and
determine if they're going to evaluate
if the student moved across state lines
or from another country uh the team has
an obligation and a right to reevaluate
that child if they feel like it's
necessary um in the meantime while they
make that decision they still have have
to implement that current I to their
best ability and to meet those Services
needs within that I um the second part
that I wanted to draw your attention to
with lines 14 15 of the proposed bill to
me I worri that it puts the onus on the
parent alone Prov buide a copy of that I
to the school um I I would with military
family that might get difficult if they
are moving frequently they may lose
track of documents a little easier than
some other families so I'm worry that
that puts all the hus on military family
to provide that document and not the
school for which they are coming from so
I maybe just encourage you to look at
that language and maybe an and or in
there um not just solely relying on that
parent to provide a copy of that I
to
thank you very much questions from the
committee thank you very much and the
Ryan Mr chairman and education committee
um I'm here to support this bill um for
those of you that don't know I am US
Army retired in 2018 and I support or
spend a lot of time supporting disabled
veterans and Veterans I just just came
back from Washington where I was
approached by a higher up from DOD who
said that there were a lot of complaints
coming through the inspector General's
office about IEPs and special education
issues and he told me to get on that so
I don't know how or why people think I
can magically make things happen but I
do support this bill I can say for sure
there are some parents who choose to
leave their kids in DOD EA schools and
move other places um or bring their kids
so I I have a friend who's in the Army
who's ly stationed at Ford drum but his
kids are here um and so they're playing
different issues with moving around
putting kids in different locations
based off what's best for their kid we
have what we call the Exceptional Family
Member Program in the uh in the military
which is supposed to try and support
these family members but the onus really
is on the family at most of the time to
have the records to get the meetings to
do the everything because we're the ones
responsible at the end of the day so I
do want to support this bill I was told
that there were a number of complaints
coming through the inspector General's
office ours is one of the states that
does not have an education Jag attorney
um which I will work on trying to do uh
but there has been I also was approached
by someone who who was having some
issues with her school district in just
getting the IEP up and running felt like
there was a lot of push back so I just
wanted to let you know that this is
affecting people um and people may not
be aware of it because they don't think
of oh yes this person might be a
military or in my own town lenary we
have a reserve base and the
superintendent didn't even know there
were military kids in the school and
he'd w a propose star Grant so I do
support this bill I do believe there may
be some issues with the language but I
hope you will consider passing it thank
you any questions from the committee
thank you very much Mr chair I have a
question of you yeah as I look at this
bill we've talked a lot about IEPs Etc
but isn't the focus of this bill dealing
with the U witness fees that the
highlighted I mean this I mean this is
the current language is here what we're
what we're focused on is really the
witness fees is that correct that's
that's what is in this is that one is
new the following new paragraph see at
the top all right thank you and so what
you need to do is look at this and then
read that compact that's what we need to
do in my suggesting is if we're going to
do it too we should put it in one
place you know the military have really
came in on this Compact and there was a
lot of discussion on this and we had
folks coming in because at that time we
had not just dot kids we had kids who
were in The International Schools we
also had folks which are not in the
military that were working on DOD basis
do a do Department of Defense basis DOD
and moving just as much and you know
yeah I too have been yes Fort sale Fort
Fort Hood Fort Dicks all those places
are moving and
it's important to me I thought we had it
together and I'm going to look make sure
that we do have this the way we want
it um so with that we're we're done the
hearing here and we got to roll into the
next hearing which we have scheduled for
today uh which is
1469 relative retention of individual
records
thank you Mr chair uh for the record
Karine cascaden Coos District 5 and to
add I was an elementary school principal
for 23 years of one school due to budget
cuts I inherited two other schools uh
superintendent of three different
districts um over a 12E period uh this
bill I am presenting on behalf of the
Department of Ed it's relative to the
retention of individualized Education
records um what the department is
suggesting is to add paragraph
three um so that they have the ability
to actually in implement the law um that
describes when records can be um
destroyed and how long they need to be
retained uh based on what the districts
are what what what the districts have as
a procedure every every district has the
policy it's
ehb on the process for special ed um
records and upon High School
graduation there is um a process that if
a parent wants um a record destroyed
they need to put it in writing I'll let
them give you the specifics the timeline
is you know up to age 26 and then um
when the child reaches 30 uh then the
records can be destroyed unless the
parent requests not to so um that's
available on any student on any school
district website in terms of the process
but for the bill um the law already has
that 26th birthday and 30th
birthday um in it and it's adding this
paragraph three that says they're going
to be on the same school schedule as the
school
districts
um and in terms of following federal law
federal law does not impose any time
limits on record
retentions of special ed records any
questions for represent
cascaden superintendent
cascaden representative
Ryan that's yeah yep we got
it yeah these are 1382 right here I just
have a very quick Point um I just wanted
to say that with these records um it's
very important that they get retained
because parents often find themselves in
need of the records to prove something
for their child whether it's hipic
waivers ddu um so they do if if there
are any changes made I would hope it
would be to further and not diminish so
that was the only point wanted to make
thank you very much are there any
questions for Miss
Ryan thank you very much and uh Rebecca
fet from the
support thank you representative LED um
we requested this bill because there was
no record retention for us in regards to
the records we have for special
education we are not the um special
education of record the district has
those but we do have this within our
special education information system
student records and we're just asking
that we be allowed to follow the same um
retention schedule as school districts
so that we do not um hold on to these
records in
perpetuity are there any questions of
the department yes currently what thank
you uh what is the current when it says
retention schedule or the the same
schedule as districts what is that
schedule so as representative cascaden
had said it's up to the age of 26 and
then it can be requested up to the age
of 30 thank you
yep representative Heath quick question
I know how much space you have at the
department um did you digitize those
records yes it's all electronic records
but the more we have the more servers we
need thank
you okay further
questions thank you very much are there
any other cards for
1469 not seeing thank you very much
hearing and we are ahead of schedule so
if anybody has to get up and walk a
so um yes Mr chair I do have the
Amendments here for 1639 and 1480 good
we will we will address those okay today
thank
you
oh
okay we're going to go forward and take
up the last bill that we have for
hearing today that's HB
1695 this is relative to the release of
student personally identifiable
cordelli uh thank you Mr chairman and
honorable colleagues on the education
committee um I'm glad to close the day
for you um this is uh I think relatively
uh simple bill in in my mind anyway um I
think earlier today we heard about a a
federal statute called
furpa and um if you want definition or
anything it's uh on page 503 in your
book uh f is the family educational
rights and Privacy
Act um and it comes into
play um with this
legislation um because furp is intended
to protect student
privacy however there is a section of
furpa that I'd like to address and
that's part of the handout that I sent
around the um student guide to
furpa um hopefully it got around to
everybody but on page three in the
section in the uh middle of the page
there is a section um titled School
official and in that section it says
also under the school official except
exception to the consent requirement the
consent meaning a a parental consent to
release student information private um
uh Privacy Information protected
information um furpa permits a school to
disclose pii the private information
from educa educational records to
contractors
Consultants uh volunteers and another
third parties to whom the school has
outsourced institutional services or
function provided the outside party and
then it lists four criteria including
that the outside um party is performing
an Institutional service or
function and this comes into play um
particularly in the uh past few years
under various programs um grant program
to provide um health and mental health
services um to uh students in our
schools and um one of the um I can't
remember the name of the grant but uh
widely um used uh third party is the
behavioral health Improvement Institute
at Keen State College uh to perform
these services for
students um and that's allowed under
furpa so you know I'm not going to take
on furpa today um but what I do want to
do is put forward this bill that
indicates that
if the information is given by a third
party under furpa in accordance with
furpa with the consent exception that I
just talked about and you'll see it on
lines 9 through 12
if person if student personally
identifiable data is released to a third
party parents of the student shall be
informed within School excuse me 14
business school business days of the
release to whom the data was released
what information in Rel was released and
the Ed educational purpose for which
that information was
released um I'm not quarreling with the
um uh
releasing of that information but I
think the least we can do is let parents
know that their students information is
being released to whom and
why um so that's all this bill does is
to inform the parents about the release
of information which is permissible
under federal law um you know I I think
uh
transparency um is something that we
need to pay attention to um we we've
talked about uh today a number of times
about parent engagement and um we've
talked about parents rights and
transparency I I think this is in line
with those topics and the least we can
do is to notify the parent if their
students information is being released
to a third party so thank you very much
thank you very much are there any
questions for representa Cordell yes
representative cascaden thank you than
you Mr chair uh thank you for taking my
question sure so does the new language
um in this bill about personal identif
pii does that negate the directory
information in
fura there directory information certain
guidelines right without consent I mean
I don't know why you would want to
anyway but nonetheless F identifies that
right right this is specifically related
to the
uh
exception that they can release
information to a third party without
consent um I don't think it um is
impacted by directory
statutes this is um a narrow um uh
exception that I'm trying to
address further questions bson
Heath just a quick question I remember I
worked at the department so long ago and
um we were doing the state assessment
and um we went round and round and round
with Neil Kirk about this very subject
um what we had to do we had to um
anybody who looked at the data had to
sign a special release saying that they'
never divulged the information to
anybody um but the testing company they
held the the information and there was
uh we always had student identifiers and
that's the only only thing that we used
to work with um I I don't know of any
instance when we release student
information um I I think if I could I
think answer your question I think um
maybe three or four years ago we did
pass legislation allowing some student
information to be sent to the testing
company so that they the testing company
could send out the test scores to the
students exactly yes um but I don't know
I don't ever remember us
giving student identification
information to a third party other than
the testing company right um under these
um under some of these grants that are
being made available and to third um
third parties such as the one that I
mentioned um that information is being
available is being made available um and
it's it's allowable
I'm not quarreling with that it's just
that I think parents should be
notified um and I think there might be
someone behind me who has um maybe a
better um memory on those um grants than
than I
do represent
leus is there a reason we're only
fact
um I I I um I I I don't know what
difference would make if it was before
the fact because it's allowable under
federal
law thank
you further
questions thank represent
board thank you Mr chair Mike thank you
for taking my question I was looking for
your reference for parents and I'm down
on toward the bottom of page three where
it says seeks or intends to enroll and a
line under that that about four lines
down says attempt to notify the eligible
student of the con but I can't find that
reference to
parents right this this exception just
allows um the information to be sent to
third
parties um without consent of the
parents okay that's the exception okay
thank
you further questions thank you thank
you very much uh represent you represent
Hall thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question are we talking about
like Power School Infinite
Campus um you know the what the schools
use to hold their data we're not talking
about that no okay no th those are um
State systems so I I think that there is
no problem um in terms of furo in that
regard okay thank
you further questions
thank
you
beran
Emy good afternoon um for the record my
name is am R Banfield I'm a parental
rights Advocate focused on education in
New Hampshire I am supporting this bill
um several years ago Democrats and
Republicans came together to support
privacy legislation for teachers working
in our Public Schools I don't know if
couple of you were here so you might
remember that um privacy rights has been
a bipartisan agenda for good
reasons one can read the Privacy
policies from edtech vendors to realize
that a student's personal information
can be shared without knowledge or
consent from the students or parents
because of the exceptions in the furpa
law there is a misconception that the
federal fle law protects a student's
personal information but there are
exceptions in that law that allow
third-party vendors to share data
without notification or
consent I support 1695 because it is
trying to close a loophole that
currently exists or deal with that
loophole however I do believe that
sharing personal data via fura could
continue
the bill as written could require an
edtech company for instance to say we
collected student data to develop our
product and enhance our
personalization It also says that they
would have to notify parents that their
students information was shared with the
third party but that doesn't require
them to name the data element shared and
there's no enforcement mechanism that I
could see Colorado's Bill hb1 1423 and
20 16 included similar similar language
but that bill did require data elements
the bill did not include a pen penalty
or an enforcement mechanism so companies
do not
comply I appreciate the sponsor's
efforts but I think it can be a better
Bill if it included a definition of
Education purpose although I just read
that and I think that is included in
there um so that might part part might
be um not
accurate um it should require any pii
disclosure first or third party or
subcontractors or Partners to name data
elements shared and purpose this should
also be a requirement of the
subcontractor and processors this would
prevent unregulated Downstream sharing
with internal Partners an example would
be the College Board selling licenses to
view student personal identified data or
Navan sharing student data with its
umbrella company who owns sever
advertising
companies there should also be an
enforceable penalty such as if edtech
company does not comply this will
trigger both or either district attorney
or attorney general investigation and
possibly a fine of $110,000 for each
violation we need to be serious about
protecting student privacy in New
Hampshire representative cordelli has
been leading this effort and I
appreciate that in the past organ
organizations like the ACLU has been a
partner along with legislators on both
sides of the political
fence I ask that you pass this bill and
possibly make an amendments including
the the things that I
suggested um that's my written testimony
I do have a couple things I did want to
mention I did sit on a Bedford privacy
task force several years ago in that
school district um to come up with a
policy that was required by law and it
basically what we were doing was trying
to close that loophole parental consent
when this data is shared that was what
we were trying to do
um so something needs to be done I think
it it should be done at the state level
because even though we worked on it in
Bedford that's certainly not going to
apply to every school district in the
State uh an example of if you're looking
for an example of how this information
gets out or how this information is
shared the uh New Mexico attorney
general and Mississippian attorney
general sued Google over children's
privacy violations there was a $93
million settlement so this is happening
it does happen that's just one of many
examples you can Google search and you
can see how student privacy VI rights
have been violated uh tends to be
selling the
information that's what it it it tends
to be but it can go further than that so
that was it thank you very much are
there any any questions from the
committee yes represent Bon thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question um I guess I'm a little
confused can can you explain more um
with spe specifications what information
is being shared um and how is that
happening here in New Hampshire can you
give like a a real specific example
please sure so when the kids have their
Chromebooks and they sign on to an app
when they sign on to to any vendor any
vendor that's that's coming into the
school that that you're using on a
computer that there is information being
passed on to that vendor and if you read
the vendor's privacy policy it will
state this information is being
protected per furpa so everybody reads
that and thinks okay it's protected but
they don't understand all the time is
that and we discussed this at the
Bedford when we when we did this at the
Bedford um task force what they don't
understand is that you think that the
Privacy is protected you think that they
can't go any further than that vendor
well number one that vendor could be
sold number two um they can uh exploit
the furpa exception the fple loophole
and so somebody else comes along and
says well we want to research that
information on these students can you
now give us your in like when I talked
to the Bedford superintendent he was
like you know I'm not giving away
information I said yes but once you've
given it to these vendors once you've
given it away they can then send it they
can then sell it they can do if they
call themselves an education researcher
they can then share it that's the
exception in in furpa so it's happening
with any kind of vendor that is coming
through the Chromebooks or coming to the
school um it doesn't matter what vendor
it is it if you read their privacy
policies they're not private they're not
private because they will site furpa but
you have to understand that furpa has
those exceptions and that that
information can then leave that vendor
if they say for instance they are an
education researcher well I'm an
education researcher they're going to
give it to me I mean if if I pay the
right price for it that's what I think
this legislation is trying to do and I
think this is one of the biggest concern
for privacy rights
Advocates across the United States is
that that loophole exists and that it
hasn't been addressed in many states or
in many schools and in Bedford we we sat
down and discussed that we came up with
a privacy policy um my suggestion to
Bedford was come up with a you know
because okay do I have a consent form
for every vendor we use in the school
district how do we do this do you want
to know this information am I or am I
explaining too much I I can stop if you
want to know it if you could just kind
of summarize I'm just curious like so a
vendor would be like um if a school
district uses a
particular app or something that the
students sign on to what actual
information is the student putting on
there that's being saved or shared sure
their name their um age I mean it
depends vendors collect different
information depending on what what that
their scores their reading scores their
if they're using an app for math
anything like that um I don't think that
those are really what
sometimes you and I would consider to be
a big deal maybe that's not something
that would bother you if that
information was you know passed on um
but regardless there's other personal
information apps that they they could be
using now everything is digitalized now
um you know in the past a lot of records
were kept paper and we didn't have this
issue but um really I think back when
the the loophole
was fura actually used to require this
used to require parental consent and
then it was um that was that was changed
and I think it was 2016 if I'm not
mistaken 2016 2017 so that was changed
and then it allowed you know if you call
for the exceptions that's when the
exceptions came in I think I understand
thank you forther questions from the
committee yes representative Hall thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question do you think school districts
are aware of this and have put measures
in place to deal with it I know I mean
I've taught computers um and I'm going
to say at least six years ago we were
given a list and if if Adobe did this
then they were going to shut it down and
if another company did this and they
were really on top of what the kids
could sign in on and not and like us as
Educators we were frustrated because we
couldn't use these programs that we
wanted to use so I guess my question to
you is do you think most school
districts are aware that this is going
on and and to have measures in place I
think that they are because when when I
sat down with Bedford obviously they had
their data people in the room with us as
part of the task force so they were
aware of a lot of a lot of um privacy
issues but they need they have to know
that the furpa law has those exceptions
and that's the that's the section that
if the data people do not understand the
law that's how it's becoming um I would
call it a loophole it's a loophole so
all this information can be shared with
the
vendor and the vendor says well we're
protecting the Privacy we're protecting
the student we're protecting Copa fura
all these laws are listed so when you
look at their privacy policy and I look
at them all the time and I work with the
data security analyst and I work with
somebody who's who's um who works on
data security that yes it all appears to
be secure but if you don't know about
that fural loophole if you don't
understand that there are exceptions and
that prior to the um the change in that
law parents did have to consent before
the information could be shared the
students aren't even consenting so
students don't know where this
information is going um so having a law
in place having a a state law in place
would mean that you're you're basically
going back to the way things used to be
prior to 2016 and and protecting that
privacy um if that makes sense thank you
very much forther questions thank you
very much yeah uh Nancy
butterman Beerman we'll get it right
yeah we'll get it it's not spelled right
I got the Nancy right yeah there you go
that's the important part hi good
afternoon um I agree with everything uh
and Marie bfield just said um for HB uh
1695 we are in support of it um but uh
some of the things that you may not know
that and I found out from our school
district is that um through a right to
know uh request um personal surveys and
questionnaires were being given to the
students in my school district and some
of those were links to outside sources
so that student data and information was
not verified checked with any data
person in the school the teachers like
oh click on this link and answer these
questions and we'll find out your
personality or your learning style and
it's no big deal well every time you
click click on any link you know
information's going out those cookies
are being collected and um you know you
may think it's not a big deal but
they're collecting on everything and
they're going to figure out how to
connect you with everything um my
concern also is all the zoom classes
there was issues with zoom and zoom
collecting data and
information um and then we have the Sora
app that everybody uses to uh access
textbooks where's all that information
going and if you click on this book you
know what does that say about you and
then we're going to try to you know have
this information for you and then um
finally since we seem to be focusing on
mental health and everything where's all
that data going because you know they're
collecting it digitally and so then as
an adult if you go to get a job or you
go to join the military or do anything
else who's got that information on you
and is that going to keep you from
getting a job or joining the military
because of some link that you clicked on
in third grade that your teacher said
was okay so again personal information
they're collecting it everywhere and
they're so far ahead of us and we can't
even fathom what they're doing but it's
all out there and it's all sold for a
price so thank you thank you very much
are there questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you very
much are there any more pink cards on
this bill not seeing any we're going to
down and we are going
to are are we good for this re mil yes
we are are we good for this with our
here yeah we'll start with the first one
for
today so we're going to go into
executive session right now and we're
going to be looking at HB 16
39 and
we I think everybody should have the
Amendments that came back for this and
the other Bill if you don't we have some
extras up
here okay
so you want to make the recommendation
repr c c you because you're you're the
everything no no no no no no no no just
just from your chair say oh I make a
recommendation we go into exec session
1639 1639 this a bill dealing with
children with disabilities placed at
State facilities for detained or
adjudicated youth okay I make a motion
OTP on the amendment House Bill 1639
represent McDonald you make a second yes
second thank you uh represent cascaden
do you have care for any discussion or
do you have something else to add
oh um well um yes I recommend that you
OTP this bill um because the language
that we added um you'd like to introduce
Amendment oh okay well this is a
training session right 0277 H okay like
to oh yes okay so I'll introduce
Amendment um 2024
0277 H and representative McDonald I'll
second amendment 0277 H and repes C can
you like to speak to your Amendment or
not uh not thank
you represent McDonald how about you no
further comment is there any further
discussion from the committee not seeing
yes representative cordelli yes
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative
Pell
yes representative Miler yes
representative Cornell no she's not here
okay sorry representative Tanner yes
representative Keith
yes representative Hall yes say here
representative bbon yes representative
cascaden yes representative Damon yes
chairman lad yes 16 Ys no Nays and four
not voting now repres representative Cas
do you have a blur already done for this
yes and I'll second thank you very much
so we have a motion on the floor is otpa
on HB 1639 made by uh representa
cascaden and second by represent
McDonald any further
discussion mam clerk it's yours
okay hang on
second okay motion is otpa uh
representative cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative beler yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative
Pell yes representative Miler yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Heath
yes representative Hall yes
representative albon yes representative
cascaden yes representative Damon yes
and chairman lad yes 16 Y no NS and for
not voting representative cascaden do
you consent for that everybody good
represent cascaden do you have a blur
already done on this next one yes I do
would you please make a
motion hold on it is
1480 1480 let let her clerk catch up to
us hang on a second
okay
uh
hospital it's 14 1480 and repesent kiss
Cen will I'm calling on her to make a
motion I make a motion for
OTP House Bill 1480 second and second by
represent
McDonald uh represent cascad do you care
to speak or do uh have another motion I
have another motion for an amendment for
house Bell
second what what the number so we need
the number of it you know 0269 H okay
discussion we're just Clerk's catching
yep okay T we're on the amendment right
now it's Amendment
0269 on
1480 and motion made by representative
cascaden and second by representative
rooll representative cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative beler yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
Miler yes representative Tanner yes
representative Heath
yes representative Hall yes
representative Balon yes representative
cascaden yes representative Damon yes
chairman lad yes 16 Y no n and for not
voting would you like to make a motion
rep yes I'd like to make a motion uh
otpa
1480 second by
McDonald further discussion on part of
anybody not seeing
any
CL
second uh representative cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative beler yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative
Pell yes representative Miler yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Heath
yes representative Hall yes
representative bbon yes representative
cascaden yes representative Damon yes
chairman lad yes 16 y consent no Nays
and four not voting we're
good so there's other bills we can do
day9 we need amendments to any 1469 did
didn't hang on
yeah
sec do you think you can do another one
there I G to
try Mr Cher Mr chair I make a motion to
OTP
1469 second yep and represent McDonald
seconds that uh we're we're kind of
waiting for our clerk here clerk has
more it's just OTP right okay give me
1469 and we have a motion ought to pass
from representative cascaden and second
by representative
McDonald and there's nothing to be added
to this one so we're just flat out going
to do it hey notion is OTP
representative cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
Miler yes representative Tanner yes
representative Heath
yes representative Hall yes
representative Bon yes representative
KES adadon yes representative Damon yes
chairman lad yes 16 y zero Nays for not
voting any concern with uh putting in
consent obviously we want to do that
thank you very
much boy it's a three-point
shot anything else
can I think what we got is get our cars
going and warm up and get driving down
the road
um
it's a committee report a committee
majority
yeah okay so we are coming out of
executive session and we're adjourned
day so we did three bills today that's
that's pretty good yeah as simple they
were
though